ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ARE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GROW HERTZBERG.
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
WHEN MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GAS BE
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE LEAD
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR BRIAN JONES
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AND REMEMBER AGAIN THOSE REAR IN
GOD'S PRESENCE.
SOME EIGHTY FOUR SAYS.
LESTER THERE WHO PUT THEIR TRUST
IN YOU A LOVING CREATOR OF THE
UNIVERSE.
THEY DO NOT GIVE WAY TO DOUBTS
OR FEAR.
THEY TWELVE WITHIN YOUR PRESENCE.
LOVING CREATOR MAY REST WITHIN
YOUR PIECE.
WHEN INNER TURMOIL AND CONFLICT
THREATEN OUR SERENITY?
WHEN OUR LIVES ARE OVERLY FULL?
AND WE WONDER HOW WE WILL
COMPLETE WHAT IS REQUIRED.
WHEN WE HAVE CONCERN AND
APPREHENSION OVER UNRESOLVED
ISSUES?
WHEN WE ENTER INTO THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF THE WORLD?
WHEN WE HEARD FOR FRIENDS
RELATIVES AND OTHERS WHO ARE
DISTRESSED?
WHEN FEAR OF THE FUTURE RISES UP?
AND THE WAY AHEAD IS UNCERTAIN
AND UNSETTLED.
WHEN WE FEEL AT A DISTANCE EVEN
FROM YOU IN WHOM WE DESIRE TO
TRUST?
LOVING CREATOR MAY WE REST
WITHIN YOUR PIECE A MAN.
COLLEAGUES GUESTS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF SO ALEX
AND HERE.
MOVING TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLORIDA.
CENTER BRADFORD ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
NOW THIS IN DECEMBER -- BACK IN
A COUPLE [inaudible]
YEAH I'M.
I'M NOT.
GOING TO HAPPEN [inaudible]
TO YAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
ASSEMBLY FOR THE HERE. EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR PEOPLE AND HIS -- SO
WE'LL HAVE.
TO YEAH.
EVERY TIME THEY COME UP WITH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
FILE ITEM THREE FORTY FIVE AB.
SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR MITCHELL
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE TAKE
THIS ITEM UP
.
SENATE MITCHELL YOU PREPARE TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR AB SEVENTY FOUR
MISTER PRESIDENT THAT I AM.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM.
AN ACT RELATING TO THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN SENATE
MITCHELL PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AB.
SEVENTY FOUR IS THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE VEHICLE THAT WILL
CONTAIN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY STATE BUDGET.
THIS BILL WILL BE THE VEHICLE
FOR THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
THE BUDGET.
IT WILL BE USED TO RECONCILE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES THAT ARE RESULT OF OUR
RESPECTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
PROPHECIES.
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THE TENTH
OF JANUARY THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE HAS HELD SIXTY FIVE
TOTAL BUT THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
WITH ANOTHER FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING SCHEDULED FOR
THIS WEEK.
ALL OF THAT COLLEAGUES IN ORDER
TO FINALIZE THE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS OF THIS HOUSE THE
NEXT STEP IN THE PROCESS WILL BE
FOR THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
THE BUDGET WHICH WILL CONVENE%
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS WILL SEND AB SEVENTY FOUR
TO THE ASSEMBLY AND ALLOW FOR
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON THE
BUDGET TO CONVENE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL.
ANY.
ANY -- DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN.
I ARGENEAU VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR.
DETAILS NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COOK A NOW.
WITH.
WITH THAT -- MISS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
HI MORE LOCK NO MORALE
[inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY Y. CASKEY.
I WIENER.
HI WILK NO NO.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
WITH SO.
ON THE TENTH.
I WAS SO I OKAY MITCHELL CENTER
MITCHELL MOVES A CALL.%
SENATE ROUTE RUBIO [inaudible]
YES.
SENATE RUBIO WILL BE PRESENTING
SR FORTY TWO WHICH IS ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE FROM THE PRO TENS
DESK.
SENATOR RUBIO.
MR SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I MEAN THIS IS SURGERY PLEASE
READ THE BILL.
SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO WORLD
LUPUS DAY [inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE 2% SR FORTY
TWO WHICH RECOGNIZES MAY TENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS WORLD LUPUS
STATE.
LUPUS IS A GLOBAL HEALTH PROBLEM
THAT AFFECTS MILLIONS OF WOMEN
MEN AND CHILDREN OF ALL
NATIONALITIES RACES NECESSITIES
GENDERS AND AGES.
PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING OF LUPUS REMAIN
SLOW DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IT HAS ON OUR LIVES AND
THOSE AFFECTED BY LUPUS.
THERE IS A DEEP UNMET NEED TO
EDUCATE AND SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
AFFECTED BY LUPUS INCLUDING
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
CAREGIVERS.
ALL WORLD OPUS DAY LUPUS
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
CALL ATTENTION TO THE NEED TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR MEDICAL
RESEARCH.
ON LUPUS AND IMPROVED ACCESS TO
QUALITY MEDICAL CARE FOR PEOPLE
WITH LUPUS TODAY MEMBERS IT
GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE. TO
RECOGNIZE TO OUTSTANDING WOMEN
FROM MY SENATE-DISTRICT WHO CARE
VERY MUCH ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY
AND ARE VERY INVOLVED.
AND THEY'RE COSTLY RAISING
AWARENESS OF LUPUS AND ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY IN THE SENATE
GALLERY THIS AFTERNOON.
PLEASE ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE
QUANTUM UP A AND THE SPELLING
MONTANA.
ARE THE CO FOUNDERS OF LUPUS FOR
LUPUS SORRY LOOMS FOR YOU BEST A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
OFFERS A MONTHLY SUPPORT GROUP
IN POLIKARPOV FOR LUPUS
SURVIVORS AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AND CARE GIVERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN GIVING THEM A VERY WARM
WELCOME IN APPRECIATION OF THE
COMMUNITY WORK THAT THEY DO FOR
US THANK YOU WALK ON THE STILL
GOT A TELL ME TO GO TO THE THE
DEBATERS DISCUSSION ON S. R..
FORTY TWO SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I OUR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
I'M.
AYE MITCHELL.
MONNING.
HI I'M MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL.
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WIENER.
HI WILK HI I THIS SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THAT THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HI.
MITCHELL.
HI SKINNER.
HI [inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER SECRETARY I CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
ANSWERS [inaudible]
BUT THIS IS LIKE LOOKING FOR A
MEMBER DODD HI [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT A PRICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
WE'LL BE BACK TO PRIVILEGE AS A
FLOOR CENTER REQUIRED BELIEVE
YOU HAVE SOME GALLERY
INTRODUCTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT AND HAPPY
MONDAY TO YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE IS AN HONOR
TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE THE
CANAL LINES THEY ARE.
HARD WORKING NONPROFIT MARIN
COUNTY THE TO CHAMPION I
CHAMPION FOR WORKING TO BREAK
THE GENEROUSLY GENERATIONAL
CYCLE POVERTY FOR LATINO
IMMIGRANTS IN THEIR FAMILIES.
THEY'RE HERE TODAY WE CAN'T
THANK THEM ENOUGH FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE EFFORTS WE CAN GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE A
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
IS THAT THE EDGES THE ONE WHICH
IS OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MOVING ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. TOO MUCH TALKING ON
THE FLOOR VERTICALLY TO MY RIGHT.
CAN YOU CHECK YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOUR MEMBERS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE SB
SEVEN OH SEVEN I CENTER Y. KASKI.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN SB SIX
FOUR FOUR BY CENTER GLAZER.
OUR MOVIE TO THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH.
ONE TWELVE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
THREE SIXTEEN SENATE BILL SEVEN
TEN SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE SENATE BILL
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
SENATE THIRD READING.
FIRST ITEM UP IS FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SIX SB FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR ALLEN ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE.
NEXT ITEM UP FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SB THREE FIVE NINE
BY SENATOR MORLOCK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 359% OR MORE LOCK AN
ACRYLATE TO ELECTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES A A NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS IN NEWPORT BEACH
OPPOSE THE BUILDING OF A
CONDOMINIUM HIGH RISE TOWER THAT
WAS APPROVED.
BY ITS CITY COUNCIL ALTHOUGH IT
AT FAULT ALL THE CODE PROVISIONS --
THERE WAS JUST A A REAL
FRUSTRATION WITH THE PARTICULAR
PROJECT AND IN ORDER TO GATHER
THE NECESSARY SIGNATURES TO
QUALIFY A MEASURE FOR THE BALLOT
THE OPPONENTS WERE REQUIRED.
BY THE CITY COUNCIL TO ATTACH A
COPY OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT.
SOME ONE THOUSAND PAGES.
MISTER PRESIDENT -- PERMISSION --
TO PROVIDED A PROP GRANTED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS THIS IS
WHAT EVERY PETITION GATHER HAD
TO CARRY ALONG WITH THEIR
PETITION -- ARE THROUGH THE CITY
AT THE GRANT TO THE ABILITY TO
PUT SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT.
I'LL PUT THAT DOWN BECAUSE IT'S
KIND OF HEAVY.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY HAD TO
CARRY AROUND.
ALTHOUGH I MAY NOT HAVE
NECESSARILY AGREED WITH WHAT
THEY WERE DOING -- THE
OPPOSITION.
THAT THAT WASN'T THE POINT THE
POINT WAS HOW COULD WE GET SO.
CLEVER TO MAKE IT SO DIFFICULT.
FOR OUR TAXPAYERS ARE CITIZENS
TO OBTAIN SIGNATURES SO SB THREE
FIFTY NINE COLLEAGUES TRIES TO
FIND A COMPROMISE BETWEEN AN
OWNER'S DOCUMENT.
AND NO PROJECT DETAILS AT ALL.
WE'RE ASKING THAT ATTACHING
SPECIFIED DECLARATIONS TO
REFERENDUM PETITIONS PETITIONS
BE A REASONABLE IN POSITION AND
NOT A CUMBERSOME OBSTACLE TO THE
EXERCISE OF PARTICIPATING.
IN GOVERNMENT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY AT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS BILL IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE.
MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO UP NEXT ITEM
ONE THIRTY SB FOUR HUNDRED BY
SENATOR UMBERG.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FOUR HUNDRED BY SENATOR
UMBERG AND ACT WILLING TO BE
COOLER AIR POLLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- THIS BILL PERTAINS
TO EXPANDING THE VOUCHER PROGRAM
FOR THE CLEAN MOBILITY OPTION T
E. BIKES IF YOU HAVEN'T WRITTEN
ANY BIKE YOU SHOULD A ROAD WIN
OVER THE WEEKEND IT'S A BOTH A
CLEAN AND EFFICIENT -- WAY TO
TRANSPORT ONESELF -- IT IS -- A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL SIMPLY ADDS
BIKES THE BIKE VOUCHERS TO THE
PROGRAM -- DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG.
ANY OTHER FURTHER THIS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING NINE THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
YOUR EACH ANATOMIST ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO BUT NEXT IS
ITEM.
ONE THIRTY ONE SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR UMBERG.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR UMBERG RELATIVE TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS -- SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE SIMPLY REQUIRES
THAT ALL CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES NOT
JUST CAN'T CAN'T REALLY CONTROL
COMMITTEES.
THE RECEIVE CONTRIBUTIONS
TOTALING TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
MORE IN A CALENDAR YEAR TO STEPS
TO SINGLE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
ACCOUNT AT A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION WITH IN CALIFORNIA
IT ALSO PROVIDES A BANK ACCOUNT
NUMBERS.
ON A COMMITMENT COMMITTEE
STATEMENT OF ORGANIZATION WILL
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL ARJUN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS BILL IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS THE BILL
PASSES THIRTY EIGHT ZERO ON
URGENCY THAN THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
ON THE MEASURE [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR SB SIX THIRTY NINE
MITCHELL.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY NUMBER SENATOR
MITCHELL AN ACRYLATE HEALING
ARTS.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATE BILL SIX THREE
NINE WILL STRENGTHEN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS SURROUNDING MEDICAL
CREDIT CARDS OFFER TO PATIENTS
BY MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
CURRENTLY CONSUMERS RECEIVE
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT MEDICAL
CREDIT CARDS BUT OFTEN.
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW
SOMETHING CALLED DEFERRED
INTEREST PROVISIONS MAY WORK
COLLEAGUES I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE.
YOU GET CAUGHT OFF GUARD WHEN
THEY'RE FINANCED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
YOU PAY OFF NINE HUNDRED BY THE
INTO THE INTRODUCTORY PERIOD BUT
THEN HIT WITH 27% INTEREST RATE
CHARGED NOT ON THE REMAINING
BALANCE OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS THE
POTENTIALLY ON THE ORIGINAL
CHARGE OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS MEDICAL
PROVIDERS FROM OFFERING PRODUCTS
WITH DEFERRED INTEREST
PROVISIONS AND PROHIBITS MEDICAL
PROVIDERS FROM CHARGING TO
MEDICAL CREDIT CARDS SERVICES
NOT YET RENDERED.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TO
KNOW WELCOME BACK COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
SB -- SIX THIRTY NINE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT OVERSEES HE'S
LEARNING -- COMPANIES -- THEY
HAVE A A PRETTY GOOD RATING --
94% OF THEM HAVE A FIVE STAR
RATING. 80% OF THESE LOANS ARE
PAID OFF AND 20% ULTIMATELY.
HAVE THE INTEREST CHARGE THAT
ARE -- APPLY TO THEM
[inaudible]
OF THERE ARE A LOT OF MEDICAL
SERVICES SAID UNFORTUNATELY --
SOME INSURANCES DON'T PAY FOR
THAT.
ARE NECESSARY AS AN EXAMPLE --
ORTHODONTICS YOUR WORK -- I CAME
FROM A VERY -- LOW INCOME FAMILY.
I HAD A SIGNIFICANT OVERBITE.
I HAD TO WEAR BRACES NOT THREE
YEARS NOW FOR YEARS I HAD TO
WEAR BRACES EIGHT YEARS TO GET
THE TEETH BACK INTO THE THE
MOUSE.
WHEN I WAS -- BORN I ALSO HAD --
SOME LARGE EARS THAT WERE SO
LARGE I WAS -- BULLIED IN SCHOOL
WHEN.
THE PARENTS -- GOT SOME MONEY --
LOAN TO THEM.
TO HAVE MY EARS SURGICALLY TEN
BACK TO MY HEAD [inaudible]
SO.
I WORRY THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE FORCING A LOT
OF THESE.
FAMILIES THAT WANT TO GET THE
SELECTIVE BUT NECESSARY HEALTH
SERVICES. TO GO -- TO PAYDAY
LOAN PLACES PAY EXORBITANT
INTEREST.
SURRENDER APART THEIR CARS UP
FOR COLLATERAL LOSE THEIR CARS --
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF SURGERIES
THAT PEOPLE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
LIQUIDITY. TO PAY FOR THE
SERVICES AN EXAMPLE IF YOU GOT A
TRIAL THAT -- NEEDS LASIX
SURGERY ABOUT WANT TO DRIVE A
CAR THE YOU KNOW -- WE PREFER.
NOT TO HAVE THE GLASSES WITH
THEM ALL THE TIME -- THE LEASE
BECAUSE THEN SAFER AND MORE IT'S
MORE PREVALENT TODAY BUT IT
STILL COULD BE RATHER
[inaudible]
RATHER COSTLY [inaudible]
AND SO.
YOU KNOW WE AS AN INSTITUTION
TRY TO BAN -- PREDATORY --
INSTITUTIONS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE THOSE LESS FORTUNATE THAN
OURSELVES.
I WORRY THAT I THINK THE
INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR ARE
GOOD HERE.
BUT I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE
PUSHING A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO GET HESE
MEDICAL SERVICES ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER. TO GO TO PREDATORY
LENDERS -- WHEN IN FACT 80% OF
THEM PAID THESE LOANS OFF --
WITHOUT -- PAYING A LOT OF
INTEREST OR ANY INTEREST AT ALL.
SO -- YOU KNOW I I REALLY.
HOPE THE CHILL Là YOU LOOK AT
THE DETAILS OF THIS BILL I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO HURT THOSE OVER
TRYING -- TO HELP AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NO VOTE IN SB.
SIX THIRTY NINE THANK YOU CENTER
STONE.
ANY OTHER DEBATE THING NONE
CENTER MITCHELL WOULD YOU CARE
TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF MY GOOD
INTENTIONS.
Là AND WITH THAT LET ME CLARIFY
WHAT THE BILL ACTUALLY THIS --
IT DOES NOT PROHIBIT.
MEDICAL CREDIT CARDS. ONE TWO IT
DOES NOT PROHIBIT 0%
INTRODUCTORY OFFER YOU OFFER
PERIODS.
NUMBER THREE IT MERELY PROHIBITS
THE CHARGING OF INTEREST ON
AMOUNTS ALREADY PAID OFF.
KNOWN AS DEFERRED INTEREST.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID IF.
WITH THE PRIMARY COMPANY WHO
PROVIDES THIS THIS CREDIT
OPPORTUNITY SAYS THAT 80% OF THE
LOANS ARE PAID OFF DURING THE 0%
INTEREST PERIOD.
THAT'S A GREAT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE 20% THAT
AREN'T.
THAT ARE ASKED TO PAID INTEREST
AND A AT A HIGHER THAN AVERAGE
INTEREST RATE.
ON PORTIONS OF THE LOAN THEY'VE
ALREADY PAID OFF.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THERE IS
NOTHING IN THIS BILL.
THAT ELIMINATES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED CREDIT.
THEY HAVE A MEDICAL PROCEDURE
DONE TO GET IT.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IT DOESN'T ELIMINATE THE 0%
INTEREST PERIOD IT DOES NOT.
WHAT IT SAYS IS DEFERRED
INTEREST PROVISIONS?
OPPORTUNISTIC FOR THOSE WHO CAN
AFFORD THEM THE LEAST. FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THE LET ME JUST CLARIFY.
THAT THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND UP TO
THIS POINT HAS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTE.
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BELL.
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I'D RATHER [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
OUR GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO -- BURKE.
IOWA CASKEY HI I WINNER
[inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
NO.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHIANG.
HUESO I DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO.
HI TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK
THE PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR MORALE.
FOR MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
UP HERE IN THE CALL IF THEY'RE
STILL HERE HOLD ON THERE THEY
ARE STAND UP YOU HER STAND UP
THIS IS A UNIVERSITY REDLANDS
GUYS FROM MY DISTRICT.
AND LOVE A MALL POLITICAL
SCIENCE MAJORS.
AND TAKE YOUR IN A VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR MORALE IF YOU WANT TO
IMPRESS YOUR CONSTITUENTS CAN
YOU RECITE THE OCT TAMALE FOR
THEM [inaudible]
A YES I
STAYING WITH PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR FROM THE PRO TEM'S
GAS SENATOR.
ALLEN.
MEMBERS IT IS A GREAT HONOR
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE A VERY
SPECIAL ANNIVERSARY THAT IS
COMING UP THIS WEEK.
ON MAY TWENTY THIRD MARKS THE
ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE FOUNDING OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND LOS
ANGELES -- THAT WONDERFUL CAMPUS
THAT HAS PRODUCED SO MANY
EXTRAORDINARY PEOPLE I THAT IS
BANNED SUCH A EXTRAORDINARY
ASSET FOR THE PEOPLE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE IN IN IN
LOS ANGELES HI WE HAVE SOME.
ADMINISTRATORS AND FACULTY SOME
STUDENTS AND ALUMNI JOINING US
HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND IN
THE GALLERY TO WIN IS THIS VERY
SPECIAL OCCASION.
WE HAVE SCOTT WALKER WHO'S THE
UCLA EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR
AND PROVOST WHO'S HERE TO ACCEPT
A RESOLUTION ON BEHALF OF OUR
STATE SENATE YOUR UCLA COURSE IS
VERY.
SPECIAL TO ME IS THE REASON WHY
I'M A CALIFORNIAN MY MY MOM AND
DAD MET -- AS GRADUATE STUDENTS
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN.
ANOTHER BLUE AND GOLD
INSTITUTION AND MY DAD WAS GIVEN
A JOB OFFER AT UCLA WAS NOT
BROUGHT OUT TO THE CAMPUS BUT
BUT WAS GIVEN A JOB OFFER.
AND DECIDED WITH MY MOM TO MAKE
THEIR WAY WEST IN INSIDE AND
SEEN EITHER OF THEIR IN WEST THE
MISSISSIPPI BEFORE AND THEY THEY
CAME WESTON AND BUILT WONDERFUL
LIVES AND CAREERS FOR THEMSELVES --
IN LOS ANGELES IN AN AT UCLA AND
I GOT A CHANCE TO GROW UP ON
AROUND THAT CAMPUS GOING TO THE
GAMES HANGING OUT ROLE FALL WITH
THE ENGLISH DEPARTMENT WAS BASED.
IN AND GETTING A CHANCE TO SOAK
IN THAT EXTRAORDINARY
INTELLECTUAL ATMOSPHERE THAT
ENVIRONMENT THAT EXISTS ON THE
CAMPUS -- MY BROTHER AND AT
MEETING HIS WIFE ARE YOU STILL A
AYE INTO TEACHING AT THE LAW
SCHOOL THERE AS AN ADJUNCT.
AND IT'S IT'S SO IT'S VERY
SPECIAL TO MY FAMILY -- AND IT'S
ALSO SOMETHING IT'S BEEN SO
SPECIAL TO OUR REGION IT'S GOT
THIS TRY PARTY MISSION OF
EDUCATION RESEARCH AND SERVICE.
AND NOW OF COURSE WE WE WE SEE
THE UCLA WAS JUST RANKED BY U.
S. NEWS WORLD REPORT AS THE
NUMBER ONE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY IN
AMERICA.
IT'S CONCISE SEE THAT AS A
BERKELEY LAW LIME IT'S HARD TO
ADMIT -- BUT BUT IT USUALLY IS
ALSO CONSISTENTLY IN THE TOP TEN
GLOBAL -- WORLD UNIVERSITY
QUALITY RANKINGS BYE.
BY BY BY THE EXPERTS.
NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAY IS PROUD OF WE IT'S BEEN
HOME TO FOURTEEN NOBEL PRIZE
WINNERS NINE NATIONAL MEDAL OF
SCIENCE WINNERS. THREE PULITZER
PRIZE WINNERS AND OF COURSE
THIRTY EIGHT ACADEMY AWARD
WINNERS.
I ALSO EXCELS ON THE FIELD IT
WAS THE FIRST SCHOOL IN THE
NATION TO REACH ONE HUNDRED
MAGICAL NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIPS.
THEIR ATHLETES BOAST TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE OLYMPIC MEDALS.
MORE THAN HALF OF THEM OF COURSE
OUR GOALS WHICH IS APPROPRIATE
FOR OUR STATE.
SO -- THIS WEEK UCLA OFFICIALLY
TURNS ONE HUNDRED I'M JUST SO
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO REPRESENT
THESE WONDERFUL FOLKS IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE WE CAN'T WAIT
TO SEE WHAT THE NEXT ONE HUNDRED
YEARS HAS IN STORE. FOR THIS
EXTRAORDINARY INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER LEARNING.
MY NIECE IS THERE NOW IS AS A
FRESHMAN A FIRST YEAR STUDENT
AND I SAY WITH ALL LOVE IN THESE
GUYS AND GO BRUINS [inaudible]
SENATOR UMBERG -- THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
AS A PROUD YOU SILLY ALANIS.
I RISE TO RESPOND TO SEVERAL
QUESTIONS POSED TO ME I'M PROUD
IT'S OUR HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY I
WAS NOT THE FIRST GRADUATING
CLASS JUST TO CLEAR THAT UP.
I'M A PROBLEM FORMER RESIDENT
DYKSTRA HALL IN MY SELF ESTEEM
WAS SOMEWHAT AFFECTED IF YOU DID
NOT SENATOR ALLEN MY FRIEND FROM
SANTA MONICA DID NOT MENTION Y
NAME AMONG THE ALUMNI BUT I'LL
I'LL LET THAT PASS.
SO -- I I JOIN YOU IN
RECOGNITION OF THAT ILLUSTRIOUS
INSTITUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER ON BURKE
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO
RISE BUT WE CAN NOT A RECOGNIZE
THE ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
UCLA WITHOUT RECOGNIZING THE
FOUNDER WHO CREATED TO
LEGISLATION TO CREATE.
UCLA AND THAT'S FREDERICK
ROBERTS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN LEGISLATURE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IN
ADDITION TO RECOGNIZING THE
UNIVERSITY LET'S RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT FREDERICK
ROBERTS MADE.
AN AUTHOR IN THE LEGISLATION TO
CREATE THE UNIVERSITY.
HEY DEFENDER BRADFORD.
SO WELCOME FELLOW BRUINS TO THE
TO THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER TO
TAKE A PHOTOGRAPH WITH OUR OUR
WONDERFUL GROUP OF OF STUDENTS
FACULTY LEADERS.
AND AND AND PROFESSORS AND ALSO
STAFF WE ALSO I WILL MENTION
THAT.
SOMEWHERE HERE IS OUR IS YES
RIGHT HERE THE THE FAMOUS AND
WONDERFUL -- CAITLYN HASHI WHO
YOU MIGHT RECOGNIZE FROM.
HER HER EXTRAORDINARY
PERFORMANCES AS A GYM THIS FOR
THE UCLA TEAM WE WERE QUITE ABLE
TO WIN THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
THIS YEAR BUT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
HERE HOPEFULLY THE NEXT OLYMPICS
WILL SEE -- I'M I'M PREDICTING
IT NOW YOU GOTTA KEEP TO THAT
GOLD MEDAL WINNING TRADITION HOWYOU SEE THEY WERE SO PROUD YOU
WERE SO PROUD OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENT LEADERS.
ACADEMICALLY ATHLETICALLY --
PHILANTHROPIC LEE IN SERVICE
THANK YOU AND AND AND
CONGRATULATIONS HAPPY BIRTHDAY
UCLA.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PHOTOGRAPHER
PHOTOGRAPHER WILL BE ALLOWED ON
THE FLOOR FOR TODAY'S SESSION
.
MOVING BACK TO THIRD READING.
BUT NOW UP TO FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FIVE SB SEVEN FORTY
TWO CENTER ALLEN ARE YOU READY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SOME FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER AT THE PRESIDENT THAT
THIS BILL REMOVES PROHIBITIONS
ARE CURRENTLY EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT HAMSTRING.
IMPORTANT NETWORK OF PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED INNER CITY BUSES FROM
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE -- WRITERS
WITH WITH WITH RIGHTS MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE CURRENTLY
ALLOCATED EACH YEAR TO REGIONAL
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES TO
OPERATE MAINTAIN AND ENHANCE
CALIFORNIA'S INTERCITY.
PASSENGER RAIL CORRIDORS.
I THESE QUARTERS ARE BOLSTERED
THROUGH A LARGE NETWORK OF
THROUGH A PROCESS THAT BRANCH
OUT FROM RAIL STATIONS TO
CONNECT WRITERS TO OVERTURN A
FIFTY TOWNS AND COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND EVEN
INTO NEVADA.
THESE RELIABLE AFFORDABLE TRAVEL
OPTIONS ARE NOT SIMPLY BETWEEN
URBAN HUBS BUT OFTENTIMES THEY
SERVE OUT OF THE WAY MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE NO OTHER
FORM.
OF OF OF INNER CITY PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
NOW HERE'S WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE
REAL THROUGH A BUS IS OFTEN
OPERATE FAR BELOW CAPACITY.
AND PART OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
OUR CURRENT LAW.
EVEN IF THE BUS STARTS FROM A
ROUTE FROM A TRAIN STATION WITH
ALL THAT SEAT OCCUPIED -- AS IT
TRAVELS FROM ONE COMMUNITY TO
ANOTHER OFTEN GETS EMPTIER
EMPTIER MORE MORE EMPTY AS THE
ROOT MOVES A LOT.
THAT'S PARTLY BECAUSE THE
CURRENT LAW DOESN'T ALLOW THAT
BUSES RUNNING ANYWAY. TO PICK UP
NEW PASSENGERS ALONG THE WAY.
SO WHAT THIS LAW DOES IS IT
REMOVES A STEEP IN WHICH
PROHIBITS RAIL THROUGH A BUSES
FROM SELLING TICKETS. TO ANY
PASSENGER UNLESS HE OR SHE AYE
THE ROAD ON A TRAIN BEFORE
CATCHING THAT BUS OR IS WRITING
ON THAT BUS TO CATCH A TRAIN.
IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR FOR
GOVERNMENT TO BLOCK UBER A LIFT
FROM OFFERING COMPETITIVELY
PRICED RIGHTS TO PASSENGERS THAT
MIGHT OTHERWISE CHOOSE. TO WRITE
A CITY BUS AND IT'S NOT FAIR FOR
CALIFORNIA STATUTE TO BLOCK
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED BY SERVICES
FROM COMPETING AGAINST PRIVATE
COMPANIES.
ARE THIS MEASURE SPURS GREATER
COMPETITIONIN THE OPEN MARKET
PLACE TO HELP GOVERNMENTS SPEND.
TAXPAYER MONEY MORE EFFICIENTLY
IT PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVAL IT
MEANS CAME TO MY ATTENTION WHEN
I ONCE -- WAS WAS ON THAT WAS ON
IT I LITERALLY HAD TO BUY A BUS
TICKET ONCE IT PLUS THE TRAIN
TICKET AFTERWARDS JUST TO BE
ABLE TO RIDE THE BUS THAT WAS.
RUNNING ANYWAY ON AMTRAK AND
IT'S A SENSIBLE BILL IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY I'VE GOT STRIVE.
THIS BILL IS A CANDID FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING ANY OBJECT SEEING ALL
THAT THERE IS AN OBJECTION SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
MY LIVER.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
THE REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I AMBER.
OUR COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
BY.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBER [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
NICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT SB THREE OH FIVE SENATOR
HUESO.
YOU MAY PROCEED -- SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH FIVE A
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT RYAN'S LAW.
SB.
THREE OH FIVE RYAN BARTEL WAS
JUST FORTY TWO YEARS OLD WHEN HE
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH PANCREATIC
CANCER.
HE IMMEDIATELY SAW CONVENTIONAL
TREATMENTS OF RADIATION AND
CHEMOTHERAPY.
BUT THE CAT CANCER CANCER HAD
ALREADY SPREAD THROUGHOUT HIS
BODY.
HE WAS GIVING STRONG OAK OPIOIDS
MORPHINE AND FENTANYL FOR HIS --
PAIN MANAGEMENT.
BUT THIS MEDICATION -- MAINLY
PUT HIM TO SLEEP AND UNAWARE OF
HIS SURROUNDINGS HE SPENT MOST
OF THE DAY ASLEEP.
FINALLY A CLOSE FAMILY FRIEND
RECOMMENDED MEDICAL CANNABIS
FEES OF THE SEA CBD OIL.
AND THE CHANGES WERE REMARKABLE.
RYAN WAS ALERT.
AWAKE SPEAKING TO HIS FAMILY.
AND HIS YOUNG SON.
HE WAS IN GOOD SPIRITS AND HAD
AN APPETITE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN WEEKS.
HOWEVER THIS WAS SHORT LIVED.
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS AND DEEP
SUFFERING WERE RECEIVING CARE IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
ARE DENIED ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
RYAN'S FAMILY WAS FORCED TO
SEARCH FOR WEEKS FOR FACILITY
THAT ALLOWED HIM TO YOU SEE
BEAUTY OIL. TO HELP MANAGE AS
PAIN EFFECTIVELY.
IN FACT.
OF THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CREEK CREDITS MEDICAL CANNABIS
WITH NUMEROUS MEDICINAL BENEFITS
INCLUDING RICH REDUCING NAUSEA
VOMITING AND PAIN.
FINALLY OUT AFTER WEEKS OF SURGE.
THIRTEEN A FACILITY IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
ALLOWED RYAN TO CONTINUE USING
HIS C. B. D. OIL.
SADLY RYAN ONLY LIVED A FEW MORE
WEEKS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PASS PROP TWO
FIFTEEN AUTHORIZING MEDICAL
CANNABIS OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE DO NOT
ALLOW ITS USE BY PEACE PATIENTS.
IN HOSPITAL PREMISES THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CLOSE THE GAP.
BY LOVE LAW IN THOSE WHO MOST
NEED.
A COMPASSION AT THE END OF LIFE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS IF THEY POSSESS A
RECOMMENDATION BY A PHYSICIAN OR
A MEDICAL MARIJUANA CARD.
SMOKING OF MARIJUANA AND HEALTH
CARE'S FACILITIES IT'S EXPERT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED UNDER THIS
BILL.
WE HAVE MADE A NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS
TO EXPAND THE USE.
OF OF MEDICAL MARIJUANA AND AND
TO ALLOW ITS USE BUT I THINK
NOTHING IS MORE DESERVING.
THEN -- FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THEIR FINAL DAYS -- AND
INCREDIBLE SUFFERING -- MEMBERS
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE --
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I A STAND -- AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH FIVE
AND ONE TO COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HELP
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS BY
GIVING THEM ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
THE FATHER OF THE BOY THAT THIS
BILL IS KNOWN.
FOR RYAN'S LAW TESTIFIED BEFORE
OUR COMMITTEE.
AND HE SPOKE FROM THE HEART.
HIS SON RYAN WAS DYING OF CANCER
IN ENORMOUS PAIN AND SADLY AT
SUCH.
A VERY YOUNG AGE.
BUT AS WE SEE OFTEN WHEN PEOPLE
GET.
END STAGE CARE THROUGH HOSPICES
OR IN THE HOSPITAL.
THE DOCTORS OFTEN THROW
NARCOTICS ADAM THEY THROW FENTON
ALLOWED A MORPHINE ADAM DILAUDID
IN THE PROBLEM.
IS THAT YOU ARE MITIGATING THEIR
PAIN BUT IN THE LAST FEW DAYS --
LAST FEW HOURS OF THEIR LIFE ON
THIS PLANET.
YOUR RENDERING THEM TO BE
UNCONSCIOUS.
AND MANY OF THESE TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS INCLUDING RYAN WANTED
TO BE ALERT AND AWAKE.
AND SPENT EVERY PRECIOUS MOMENT
THEY HAVE LEFT ON THIS PLANET.
WITH HIS LOVE ONES.
BUT THE ONLY WAY THAT HE COULD
DO THAT.
BECAUSE HE DISCOVERED THE
CANNABIS COULD TAKE HIS PAIN
AWAY AND WOULD NOT BECOME
UNCONSCIOUS.
WAS TO CONTINUE THE UTILIZATION.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT HE
LEGALLY COULDN'T DO HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
OUR CURRENT LAWS.
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
MEDICAL MARIJUANA NOW FOR OVER A
DECADE AND WE'VE LEARNED
THROUGHOUT THIS DECADE THAT
THERE ARE MANY EFFICACIES MANY
WONDERFUL USES FOR MEDICAL
CANNABIS THAT.
WE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW ABOUT
BECAUSE FRANKLY BECAUSE WAS A
SCHEDULE ONE DRUG WE DID ALLOW
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS STANFORD
UCLA THAT WE RECOGNIZE TODAY UC
DAVIS TO STUDY.
THE MEDICAL EFFICACY OF OF
CANNABIS BUT OTHER COUNTRIES
HAVEN'T SHOWN.
IT TO BE A VERY -- GOOD DRUG.
AS A PHARMACIST I CAN TELL YOU
THE CANNABIS HAS A POTENTIAL OF
HELPING PEOPLE MANAGE THEIR PAIN.
AND WITHOUT MANY OF THE NEGATIVE
SIDE EFFECTS OF OPIOIDS.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT A DYING PATIENT SHOULD
NEVER LIVE HIS OR HER LAST DAYS.
IN NEEDLESS PAIN OR AGONY.
THE FTA ALREADY APPROVED CERTAIN
CANNABIS DERIVATIVES LIKE SEE
MEDIAN ERIN ALL.
BECAUSE OF THEIR PROVEN
MEDICINAL VALUE.
AND WHILE THE FDA HAS ADMITTED
CERTAIN VALUE TO CANNABIS
DERIVATIVES ITS INSISTENCE ON
CALLING THIS A CLASS ONE DRUG IS
MEANT A SEVERE LACK OF CLINICAL
STUDIES.
ON THE BENEFITS OF DYING
PATIENTS WHO NEEDLESSLY SUFFER
AND SHOULDN'T HAVE.
TO AND WHILE THE FTA AS
CONTINUES PRACTICE OF TREATING
MARIJUANA THE SAME AS HER WHEN
THIRTY THREE STATES NOW.
EMBRACE MEDICAL CANNABIS AS WE
HAVE LED THE WAY.
NOT BECAUSE STUDIES DONE HERE IN
THE US BUT BECAUSE OF STUDIES
CONDUCTED TO COUNTRIES LIKE
ISRAEL THE PROOF THAT MARIJUANA --
AND ITS SECOND GENER IS TRULY
HAVE MEDICINAL VALUE.
WE CERTAINLY KNOW AGAIN THAT
MARINOL VENUES FOR AIDS TO STOP
THE WASTING SYNDROME AND
CHEMOTHERAPY PATIENTS SO THEY
CAN KEEP FOOD DOWN.
AFTER THEY GET SOME OF THESE
TOXIC DRUGS OR POSTAL POISONOUS
TO THEIR BODY.
IF CANNABIS IS THE MEDICATION
ALLOWS A PERSON TO BETTER COPE
WITH PAIN AND SUFFERING THEIR
FINAL HOURS AND WE SHOULD STAND
BEHIND THEM.
AND ALLEVIATE SOME OF THAT
SUFFERING NO ONE SHOULD BE
FORCED TO INDOOR PAIN.
SB THREE OH FIVE WILL GET DYING
PATIENTS A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE
AND THEIR NUMBER TODAY'S.
AND FOR MANY HOPE.
WHAT HAPPENED A RHYME BARTEL
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO ANYONE?
AGAIN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE PAIN FREE
AND THEY'RE DYING DAYS.
AND THEY DESERVE TO HAVE
CONSCIOUSNESS TO SHARE THEIR
FINITE TIME.
WITH THEIR LOVED ONES AND THIS
BILL ACCOMPLISHES.
THAT GOAL WITHOUT I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR MY FRIEND FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR CHAMPING THIS
ISSUE AND I'LL BE VOTING FOR SB.
THREE OH FIVE AND ENCOURAGE ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE
[inaudible]
CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
AND I WILL BE SURE THAT THIS IS
A BIG SWING IN -- PHILOSOPHY FOR
ME -- AS I'VE NOT BEEN A
PROPONENT OF MEDICAL.
MARIJUANA OVER THESE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS BUT RYAN'S FATHER
JIM BARTEL IS A FRIEND OF MINE.
A FRIEND OF ALL OF OURS -- FROM
SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
AND TOLD THE VERY COMPELLING
STORY OF HIS SON'S FINAL DAYS
AND WEEKS -- IN THE HOSPITAL AND
IN HOSPICE.
AND AS A SINNER STONE HAS SPOKEN
TO THE SCIENCE OF IT.
I'LL JUST SPEAK TO THE BILL.
THE BILL IS TIGHTLY WRITTEN --
THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS ON IT THAT I THINK
MADE THE BILL MUCH BETTER.
I THINK THAT AS LEGISLATORS WE
HAVE A DUTY. FOR THOSE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE IN THE
FINAL DAYS WEEKS AND MONTHS OF
THEIR LIFE WHEN THEY'RE
TERMINALLY ILL.
I TO DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO
PROVIDE AN EASE TO THAT
SUFFERING AND PAIN.
AND I THINK THIS BILL DOES THAT.
AND I SUPPORTED AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES CENTER
BARGES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
MAY I HAVE PERMISSION TO POSE A
BILL THE THE CHAIR YES.
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT ALL
OF SENATE HUESO WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THE QUESTION.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
WOULD REQUIRE.
THESE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
I JUST WANTED TO UNDERSTAND --
BY THIS PROPOSED BILL WOULD IT
PUT THE HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
AT RISK -- OF JEOPARDIZING ANY
FEDERAL FUNDING.
CURRENTLY NOT UNDER THE THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THERE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN.
A LANGUAGE THROUGH A FEDERAL
HOUSE READ RESOLUTION.
PROHIBITING ANY FEDERAL FUNDS TO
BE EXPENDING ON PREVENTING ANY
STATES FROM AND IMPLEMENTING.
THEIR OWN STATE LAWS AUTHORIZING
THEUSE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS SO
AS LONG AS THAT LANGUAGE EXIST
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
SMALLER FACILITIES IN OUR ENTIRE
STATE IS PER PROVIDED A SAFE
HARBOR SHOULD THAT CHANGE.
THIS BILL.
WOULD PRETTY MUCH -- SUSPEND THE
SMALL.
AND AND THIS WILL LAW WOULD NOT
BE -- ENFORCEABLE IN THE STATE
THANK.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER DEBATE
CENTER HUESO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'LL
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR THEIR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
AND JUST THINK OF ALSO -- THE
BARTEL FAMILY FOR WORKING ON
BEHALF OF THE REST OF CALIFORNIA
TO PROPOSE AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
SUCH AN IMPORTANT MEASURE.
OTHER PROBABLY WATCHING HERE
TODAY SO I WANT TO THANK THEM
AND AND ALSO -- ASK -- FOR ALL
OF YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR HUESO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
I THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON. FOR TITLE I JACKSON
[inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
BY PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
HI.
WHY COUNTY?
BY WINNER.
HI WILK HI HI.
MR SEARCH A PLACE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBER MORALE.
THE FINAL TALLIES THIRTY SEVEN
YES NO NO VOTES THE MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND BY WAY OF INTRODUCTION
SENATOR BRADFORD AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M HERE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE -- AS CHAIR BANKING
AND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE -- TO PRESENT A
RESOLUTION TO CHANNEL IN ALL ON
ON HER RETIREMENT.
AS COMMISSIONER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
OF IT THE PLEASURE OF KNOWING
JAN FOR THE TEN YEARS SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE SINCE I
WAS FIRST ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND HAD SHARED MANY
CONVERSATIONS AS RELATES TO THE
HISTORY OF THIS INSTITUTION
POLICY.
AND BANKING AND OTHER FINANCIAL --
MATTERS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
JANET SPENT THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN THE PRIVATE
BANKING INDUSTRY PRIOR TO
BECOMING.
THE FIRST COMMISSIONER APPOINTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS MERGE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORPORATIONS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN HER ROLE AS
COMMISSIONER.
HAS MANY STELLAR ACHIEVEMENTS
THAT IMPACT THE LIVELIHOOD OF
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
JUST TO NAME A FEW IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SECURED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PENALTIES.
CONSUMER RESTITUTION AND
REFORMED BUSINESS PRACTICES TO
THE LENDER SETTLEMENT RELATED TO
BORROW.
BORROWER DECEPTION AND OVER
CHARGING.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SHE
HELPS FOR A LANDMARK CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT RULING WHICH
PROHIBITS PAYDAY LENDERS FROM
USING NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
SOVEREIGNTY TO AVOID REGULATION
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SHE GARNERED THE LARGEST
ENFORCEMENT SETTLEMENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S HISTORY TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOUR
PENALTIES AND RE FUNDS TO THOSE
HARMED BY LARGE PREDATORY
MORTGAGE LENDERS.
PRIOR TO HER EXPECTS LIP WORRY
LEADERSHIP IN DDO GEN ALSO
SERVED THIS VERY HOUSE AS CHIEF
CONSULTANT TO THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE ON BANKING LONG BEFORE
I WAS ELECTED.
BEFORE THAT SHE ALSO WORKED. FOR
THE FORMER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
OR SHE SERVES.
HIS SUPPORTERS EXACTLY DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA ORGANIZE
INVESTMENT NETWORK PROGRAM AND
ALSO THE NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION AS
EXACTLY DIRECTOR PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING JANET.
HER HUSBAND STEPHEN HER SON RUDY
AND LET US GIVE A BIG THANKS AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO JAN FOR ALL
OF OUR GREAT YEARS OF SERVICE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATOR GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT.
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN -- WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM -- GARDENIA AND
ALSO CONGRADULATIONS AND
CONGRATULATING -- THE COMMISSION
ON HER RETIREMENT I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF HEARING THE BANKING
COMMITTEE. FOR A BIT OF TIME AND
ALWAYS ENJOYED.
WORKING WITH HER -- SHE ALWAYS
BROUGHT SUCH -- INSIDE AND
INTEGRITY TO THE WORK -- THE
DEPARTMENT ANDI JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN WISHING HER WELL
IN HER RETIREMENT.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH AS THE
PRESIDENT I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ONE
OF THE STATE'S BASS.
A MISSPELLING HAS ALWAYS BEEN
AVAILABLE HE'S ALWAYS WORKED
HARD AND SHE'S BEEN TENACIOUS
ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMERCIAL BANKS HAVE A HARD
TIME ESPECIALLY LARGE NATIONAL
BANKS IN RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE AND SHE'S BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN ENSURING THAT
THEY KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE.
THOSE RESIDENTS WHO CALL MANY OF
OUR RURAL COUNTIES HOME.
IN YOU HAVE BEEN RELENTLESS IN
YOUR FOCUS ON ALL ISSUES OF
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS MAKING
WADING INTO THE SWAMP THAT IT IS.
A AND I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
MISS ANDREA SINCERELY THANK YOU
FOR THE BOTTOM MY HEART IT'S
BEEN AN ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE
TO WORK WITH YOU I IN YOUR GONNA
BE DEARLY MISS I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GO FAR.
THANK YOU SIR REQUIRE AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATE ALL ANOTHER CENTER
DODD.
AS OF ANOTHER FORMER BANKING
CHAIR I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK -- WITH THIS -- WENT
OVER THE YEARS AND AN ECHOING --
ECHOING THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ALWAYS SOMEBODY
THAT'S THERE -- WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU WIDE REALLY REALLY
TOUGH ISSUES I ALSO GOT TO KNOW
WERE -- WITH SOME FRIENDS AND
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO DIED A
NAP WITH HER HUSBAND ENJOY THAT
VERY VERY MUCH AND WE'LL MISS
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO IT'S FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON BEHALF PEOPLE
STAY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
.
UP NEXT IS ITEM ONE FORTY ONE SP
ONE FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD.
SECRETARY MISTER BRADFORD READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE ROLE.
PLEASE READ THE BILL SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY FIVE A SENATOR
BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY ENERGY.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU WAS
RESIDENT -- SP ONE FIFTY FIVE IS
A STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE IT'S
PROACTIVELY IDENTIFIES OUR PS TO
GOD DEFICITS AND CLARIFIES
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS OTHERS NOTHING NEW
IN THIS BUILDING ONLY EXPLAINS
OUR OUR IMPROVES UPON WHAT'S THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS EXIST.
THIS -- MEASURE PASSED -- POLICY
COMMITTEE WOULD NO NO VOTES IN A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
NO THERE IS AN OBJECTION SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
NO GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
HI HI WITH SO I HER TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
OUR MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
IRA CASKEY I WINNER.
NO.
WILK HI HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
STERN.
WELL TELL YES THIRTY TWO FOUR
KNOWS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY TWO SB ONE FIFTY SIX
SENATOR NELSON.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR NELSON AND ACT RULING
HEALTH FACILITIES.
MISS PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE THIS BILL IS BROADLY
APPLICABLE BUT TO PERPETRATED BY
A ANOTHER UNFORTUNATE SITUATION
IN THE AREA THAT I'M PRIVILEGED
TO REPRESENT.
RESULT IN THE FIRE.
NICE THE FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL.
WAS PUT OUT OF COMMISSION.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
HOSPITAL IN THE ER.
BUT IT WAS ONE OF THE FEW ACUTE
CARE FACILITIES IN ALL OF BUTTE
COUNTY.
IN A ROLE IN PROVIDING SERVICES
TO THOSE FINISHED.
THE FACILITY WAS LOST THE R. WAS
SAVE.
AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE A COMEBACK.
BUT WE SAW A NEED. TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP SOME OF THESE FACILITIES
OPEN.
EDIT REQUIRED STATUTORY CHANGE.
AFTER MEETING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSULTANTS.
WE TRIED TO CRAFT LEGISLATION
THAT WAS EXTREMELY LIMITED IN
SCOPE.
AND WOULD PROVIDE ONLY THE
NECESSARY STATUTE TO ALLOW FOR
THE RIVER.
HE ARE TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY.
STABILIZATION SERVICES.
AND UNDER THESE LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES.
HAS TO COMPLY WITH NURSE PATIENT
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
OFFICIALS IN A POSITION POSITION
BOARD CERTIFIED E. R..
MUST THE OP NOT DOCTOR MUST BE
ON SITE.
AND HAS TO ADHERE TO ALL
EMERGENCY ROOM REGULATIONS
CURRENTLY IN PLACE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
CAN APPLY FOR A TWO YEAR SPECIAL
PERMIT.
IT CAN ALSO REAPPLY TWICE.
PERMITS FOR TOTAL MAXIMUM.
OF SIX YEARS.
ANY RENEWAL OF THE SITE AFTER
THE INITIAL TO YOUR PERMIT.
WOULD REQUIRE COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENT.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT I THINK
QUALIFYING FACTOR.
IT SHOULD BE THE POLICY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA NOT TO ALLOW THE
STANDALONE EMERGENCY.
FACILITIES DEPARTMENTS OUTSIDE.
THE NORMAL CONTINUUM OF CARE.
MEANING JUST AN E. R. AND TO
ITSELF NOT CONNECTED TO A
HOSPITAL.
BUT THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES
EXTENT THAT I THINK TO JUSTIFY.
THIS BEING ONE OF THEM.
IT CAN BE A MODEL FOR FUTURE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN OTHER DISTRICTS.
WHERE IN THE HOSPITAL AND THE E.
R. ARE?
DESTROYED.
I WOULD URGE YOU.
AN AYE VOTE FOR THIS VERY
RESTRICTED THE LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCE.
BUT WHEN WE'RE IN IT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT. TO
THE NEEDS OF THE CITIZENS.
AN OPTICALLY DURING AN EMERGENCY.
THANK YOU CENTER NELSON.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CANNOT FOR
UNANIMOUS.
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
ACTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY THREE SB
THREE ONE THREE SENATOR HUESO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTEEN A SENATOR
HUESO AN ACTUAL IN ANIMALS.
THERE HUESO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SB.
THREE THIRTEEN THE CIRCUS
CRUELTY PREVENTION ACT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD MAKE IT
ILLEGAL STATEWIDE TO USE OR
ALLOW THE USE OF WILD AND EXOTIC
ANIMALS IN CIRCUSES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE WILDLIFE STATE.
MEMBERS IT'S TO PARKER FEE IT'S
DIVERSE CITY IT'S CLIMATE HAVE
PRODUCED.
AMAZING DIVERSITY OF HABITATS IN
A DIVERSE ARRAY OF BOTH PLANT
AND ANIMAL SPECIES.
WE HAVE MORE SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE IN THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO NEED HERE OR
ANYWHERE TO SUPPORT TRAVELING
ANIMAL ACTS THAT TAKE THESE
PRECIOUS CREATURES OUT OF THEIR
NATURAL HABITAT.
AND CART CART THE MORALE LE
CARGO IN MACOMB JOHN THROUGH A
FIRE LIT HOOPS AND MAKE THEM
RIDE BICYCLES AND MAKE THEM --
PERFORM HUMAN LIKE.
HUMAN LIKE -- STUNTS.
OF MANY JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA OF ALREADY INSTITUTED
A LOCAL BANDS THAT ARE SIMILAR
TO THIS BILL.
BUT TO WE MAKE -- WE MUST MAKE A
STATEWIDE OF BAN ON THIS THIS IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IT'S LONG
OVERDUE.
AND MEMBERS AS FOR YOUR AYE AYE
VOTE TODAY FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
DIDN'T I KNEW I REPRESENTED A
RULE DISTRICT.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THAT I HAD SO
MANY FUN.
ANIMAL ORGANIZATIONS IN MY
DISTRICT -- LIONS TIGERS AND
BEARS A BEAR AND TIGER SANCTUARY
IN MY DISTRICT.
I CAMEL DERRY -- THAT -- TAKES
OUR CAMELS AROUND THE COUNTY TO
SHOW OFF -- THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT THEY DO WITH THE CAMEL
DERRY -- WILD CAT SANCTUARY IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF MY DISTRICT.
AND I THINK FIVE OR SIX OTHER
ANIMAL SANCTUARIES LOCATED IN MY
DISTRICT AT ALL I HEARD FROM
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
WHEN THE BILL WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED AND THEY WERE AGHAST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS TRYING?
TO SHUT THEM DOWN AND AND PUT
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS -- BUT WE
WERE ABLE TO RAISE THOSE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND THE AUTHOR DID A VERY GOOD
JOB WITH HIS STAFF IN WITH HIS
TEAM OF NOT ONLY.
TAKING ALL OF MY CAR MY
CONSTITUENTS.
CONCERNS AND TO IT TO HEAR THEM
AND LISTEN TO THEM [inaudible]
AND NOT ONLY MOVE THEM FROM
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. TO THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- TO
WHERE THE POINT I LAID OFF IN
JUDICIARY -- NATURI SOURCES
COULD I JUST HAD SOMEONE USING
US ABOUT THE BILL.
THAT -- AS SOON AS THE AUTHOR
HAD TAKING CARE OF THEIR
CONCERNS THEY CAME INTO MY
OFFICE TO LOBBY ME FOR THE BILL.
SO I'M GLAD TO STAND HERE THIS
AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTEEN AND COMMAND THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF FOR DOING A GREAT
JOB OF MAKING THE BILL DO
EXACTLY.
WHAT IT -- WHAT HE WANTED TO DO
AND RELIEVE THE CONCERNS OF MY
CONSTITUENTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I -- ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES BETTER
MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTEEN I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR.
FOR HIS WORKING WITH DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS AND INTEREST GROUPS.
I KNOW A MONTEREY ZOO FACILITY
THAT HARBORS -- FORMER CIRCUS
ANIMALS AND MAKES THEM AVAILABLE
FOR SCHOOL CHILDREN TO LEARN
ABOUT NATURE AND THEY'RE KEPT IN
THE GREAT OUTDOORS.
IN HE ACCOMMODATED THEIR
CONCERNS I URGE AN AYE VOTE AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU CENTER MINE.
THE NOTE SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE CENTER HUESO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I WANT -- TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR WONDERFUL
WORDS OF SUPPORT.
AND ALSO TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT -- EARLY ON OF FELT
THREATENED BY THE BILL IT WAS --
PLEASED TO WORK WITH THEM TO
ENSURE THAT.
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
IMPORTANT SERVICES THEY PROVIDED
A PROVIDING SANCTUARIES TO SOME
OF THESE ANIMALS THAT SOME OF
THEM ARE DISPLACED [inaudible]
BY -- BY -- I INSTANCES WHERE --
THERE THESE ANIMALS ARE OR ARE
BEING.
TREATED WITH CRUELTY.
WHEN ONE OF THE ONE OF THEM IS
THE CIRCUSES SO WE HOPE THAT?
THEY CAN CONTINUE THEIR WORK BUT
GEN WE NEED TO END THIS PRACTICE
AND I APPRECIATE THEIR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JOINT CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
I DODD.
I'D RATHER.
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO AYE AYE OUR TITLE
[inaudible]
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROSS [inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
IRAQ OWSKI I WINNER.
HI WILK BY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL.
YEAH MEMBERS WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR SB
THREE SIXTY NINE SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
ARE YOU READY BURKE TO PROCEEDS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY NUMBER
CENTER HERTZBERG AN ACCOLADE
VEHICLES.
THAT HERTZBERG THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE IN THIS BODY AND IN THE OTHER
HOUSE ALONG WITH THE GOVERNOR
HAVE BEEN REALLY TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH.
THE CHALLENGE OF FOLKS AROUND
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS -- ONE OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
IS -- LIVING IN THEIR CARS OR
THEIR OUR BEATS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT IN THE STREETS
SO MANY -- OF THERE ARE
LITERALLY VULNERABLE AND MOVIE
ONE CITATION OR TOLL AWAY FROM
LOSING EVERYTHING.
IN ORDER TO DRESS THIS LOS
ANGELES SANTA BARBARA SOME OTHER
CITIES AROUND CALIFORNIA.
BEGAN A SAFE PARKING PROGRAM
THESE MEASURES THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE THE PROTECTED AREA FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO PARK THEIR CARS
WHILE ALSO OFFERING WRAPAROUND
SERVICES.
AND SHOWN THAT THEY CAN BE A
TURNING POINT IN PEOPLE'S LIFE.
BY THIS MEASURE DEALS WITH THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR THE
BAR AND IT NOW SINCE WHAT IT
DOES IS IT THAT WAS A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM. FOR THIS REPAIR PROGRAM
IT IT MAY EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAN AND ROLE IN THE
B. A. R. -- HI POLLUTER AND
REPAIR PROGRAM AS BECAUSE MOST
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS FIND
THEMSELVES IN CARS.
AND ARE ABLE TO A POINT OF UP
BEFORE THE FINES AND FEES TO UP
KEEP THEIR VEHICLE LAST FEW
ARRIVALS.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
ANY.
FOR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE THIS SITE MEASURE IS
A CANNON FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY SEVEN I KNOW KNOWS.
SHE SAT ON YEAH.
I BEEN CORRECTED BY THE
SECRETARY HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO YEAH.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SIX SB FOR SEVENTY FIVE CENTER
SKINNER YOU PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY FIVE A
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY THE
CAMPUS CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU I'M STILL PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
SB.
FOR SEVENTY FIVE MAKES A
CORRECTION TO SOMETHING THAT WE
DIDN'T ANTICIPATE.
IN OUR LEGALIZING OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND THAT IS
THAT.
IT IS VERY COMMON WITH IN --
INDUSTRIES FOR THE PRODUCER OF A
PRODUCT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE TO
THE DISTRIBUTOR OR THE RETAILER
OF A PRODUCT.
SAMPLES SO THAT THE DISTRIBUTOR
RETAILER CAN HAVE SOME.
PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
EXPERIENCE TO BE ABLE.
TO TALK ABOUT HOW THAT PRODUCT
WILL BE USED AND HOW IT MIGHT.
BE A VERY IN -- USEFUL PRODUCT
FOR THE PARTICULAR MARKET THAT
THAT -- RETAILERS SERVING.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT WASN'T
INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATION
SOMEONE ORDER [inaudible]
FOR MANUFACTURERS TO BE ABLE
LICENSE MANUFACTURERS TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A TRADE SAMPLE TO A
LICENSED DISTRIBUTOR OR A
LICENSED RETAILER WE NEED THIS
BILL.
THIS DOES NOT ALLOW ANY SAMPLES
FOR JUST CONSUMERS HE WON'T BE
LIKE YOU GOING INTO COSCO AND
YOU GET TO A YOU KNOW GET ALL
THE LITTLE TASTE OR WHATEVER NO.
NOT AT ALL.
IT'S REALLY ONLY BETWEEN THE
DISTRIBUTOR OR MANUFACTURER
LICENSED TO THE LICENSED
RETAILER.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES TWENTY
pSEVEN VOTES AND WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO[inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible] FIVE ROTH
[inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
OUR CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
HI WILK BY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MURTADA [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE FINAL TIME
[inaudible]
GROWTH -- TADO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
GROVE NO.
OKAY ICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
EIGHT SB FIVE THREE FIVE BY
SENATOR MORLOCK MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 535% OR
MORE LOCK IN EQUITY GREENHOUSE
GASES [inaudible]
CENTER MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF LISTENING TO PETER DRUCKER.
A COUPLE TIMES BEFORE HE PASSED
IN.
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
BUT ONE OF HIS FAMOUS.
QUOTES FROM THIS MANAGEMENT GURU.
WAS IF YOU CAN'T MEASURE IT.
YOU CAN'T IMPROVE IT.
OR YOU CAN'T MANAGE WHICH CAN
MEASURE.
THE MEETING IT YOU KNOW IFYOU
CAN'T KNOW WHETHER OR NOT YOU
ARE SUCCESSFUL UNLESS SUCCESS IS.
AND TRACKED.
WITH WILD FIRES CONTINUING TO BE
A PREDOMINANT.
THEME OF CONCERN IN THE
LEGISLATURE. ONE MISSING
COMPONENT IS THERE MASSIVE
PRODUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GASES.
IF WE MEASURE THE AMOUNT OF
GREENHOUSE GASES THESE
CONFLAGRATIONS CREATE.
IT WOULD BETTER EMPHASIZE THE
NEED TO REDUCE MANMADE WILDFIRES
IN OUR STATE.
IF WE ARE.
QUANTIFYING THE DEVASTATION BY
ITS IMPACT ON GLOBAL WARMING
THEN THE UTILITIES.
WOULD BETTER APPRECIATE.
SACRAMENTO IS INTENT ON
HARDENING ELECTRICAL ASSETS AND
THE POTENTIAL FOR UNDER
GROUNDING.
THEM OR WHATEVER REASONABLE
REMEDIES ARE AVAILABLE TO
PREVENT SPARKING ARE IGNITING
VEGETATION.
WHAT HEADLINE IN DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN READ
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES EMITTED AS
MUCH CARBON?
AS THE STATE'S ENTIRE POWER
SECTOR IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES HAVE
RELEASED EMISSIONS EQUAL TO
ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT MILLION TONS
OF CARBON DIOXIDE THIS YEAR.
SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE SIMPLY
REQUIRES THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT INCLUDES THE
GREENHOUSE GAS CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANT.
AND SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS EMISSIONS FROM
WILDFIRES ENFORCE FIRES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR MOORLACH.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CAN AT
THIS A CANDID -- FOR UNANIMOUS
[inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
SEE NO OBJECTIONS MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT TIME ONE
FORTY NINE SB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
BY CENTER JACKSON.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY THREE
PASSENGER JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO CLINICAL TRIALS.
THAT ARE JACKSON GOOD AFTERNOON
MISS PRESENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS
A MEASURE.
THAT WILL CONFORM CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH FEDERAL ARE PERTAINING TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. FOR
ROUTINE PATIENT COSTS RELATED TO
CLINICAL TRIALS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TODAY IN HEARD SOME
HEART RENDING.
STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE GOING
THROUGH END OF LIFE -- CRISES OR
DEALING WITH LIFE THREATENING
ILLNESSES THIS IS A BILL THAT
WILL MAKE SURE THE CALIFORNIA
CONFORMS WITH FEDERAL LAW WHERE
THE STANDARD IS MORE EXPANSIVE.
AND SPECIFICALLY NOT ONLY
DEALING WITH CANCER RELATED
EVENTS BUT ALSO ALL LIFE
THREATENING EVENTS THIS WILL
EXPAND THE COVERAGE -- TO
PROVIDE A FOR LIFE THREATENING
DISEASES TO BE INCLUDED AS WELL
THINGS LIKE DIABETES WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER.
DISEASES LIKE LUPUS WHICH CAN
ALSO BE LIFE THREATENING THIS IS
A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THE GIVES
CONSUMERS PROTECTION.
ODD TO ENSURE THAT THE STRONGEST
COVERAGE IS AVAILABLE TO THEM
HERE IN STATE LAW TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO
ACCESS CLINICAL TRIALS TO DEAL
WITH THESE LIFE THREATENING
CONDITIONS.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND INDICATE THAT
THE BILL HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SITTING NINE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEE NO OBJECTIONS THE MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO GOING BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SEN CENTER HURT HER TADO.
SET UP SENATOR BREAUX. OH OKAY
CENTER GROVE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN THE GALLERY TODAY WE
HAVE STUDENTS FROM BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE IN THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS CLASS AND WE JUST LIKE
TO WELCOME TO THEM THE STATE
SENATE FLOOR.
AND THEY GOT UP THIS MORNING AT
TWO O'CLOCK TO GET ON A BUS TO
BE HERE TO EXPERIENCE THE DAY IN
THE CAPITAL.
SO PLEASE WELCOME THEM TO THE
STATE CAPITOL.
CLEARLY WASN'T ABOUT SAID
SENATOR GROVE DRONES.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY ONE SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR GALGIANI
AND ACT REALLY INTO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
THERE GALGIANI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB SIX THIRTY
TWO REQUIRES THE STATE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION TO
COMPLETE AND CERTIFY A SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT. FOR
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM BY
NO LATER THAN JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRES ARE A
MAJOR THREAT IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN RECENT YEARS AS
A LANDSCAPE RESPONSE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
PREVENT FUTURE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES BY CREATING A CLEAR
PATH PLAN FOR SMART VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
SB SIX THREE TO COOK AMENDMENTS
AND SENATE EQ PASSED OUT WITH
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND CURRENTLY
HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GALGIANI.
ANY FURTHER -- DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION CENTER NIELSEN.
PRESERVATION DOWN THE SENATE IF
CENTER.
FROM THE VALLEY'S LEGISLATION
HAD BEEN ON THE BOOKS HE'S SOME
LAST FORTY FIVE OR FIFTY YEARS.
WE WOULD NOT BE EXPERIENCING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE FIRES THAT WE
NOW ARE.
FORTUNATELY NOW POLICIES HAVE
CHANGED CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT TREATING IN MANAGING.
OUR FORCE IN OUR WILD LANDS THIS
BILL IS A BIG STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION.
I THANK HER. FOR BRINGING THIS
TO US [inaudible]
BY BOAT.
THANK YOU SIR.
SEE NO OTHER DISCUSSION CENTER
GALGIANI WOULD YOU CARE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
OKAY THERE IS AN OBJECTION SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
I BRIDGES I BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER -- BY CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DODD.
I THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK I'M A REAL.
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
NO STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE [inaudible]
OUR CASKEY.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
FINAL TALLY A YES THIRTY SEVEN
ONE NO MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
T. AT ONE FIFTY TWO SB. SIX
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR HILL AND ACTUALLY
HOUSING.
CENTER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL
SIX SEVENTY TWO WILL INCENTIVIZE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AT LEAST
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS
ON THE BRISBANE BAY LANDS.
BY ALLOWING THEM NOT TO RECEIVE
AN ADDITIONAL HOUSING ALLOCATION
IN THE NEXT HOUSING CYCLE IF
THEY ZONE FOR AT LEAST EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS IN THIS
CYCLE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE A RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU CENTER HELL ANY
FURTHER THIS DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE THIS IS JENNIFER
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SAYING NO OBJECTIONS MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON FILE
ITEM [inaudible]
ONE BUT FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
THREE SB SIX EIGHT EIGHT BY
SENATOR MINING MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SENATOR MINING
AN ACT RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS CURRENTLY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS AND PAID MINIMUM AND
OVERTIME WAGES THROUGH A
CITATION ISSUED. TO AN EMPLOYER.
CONTRACT WAGES HOWEVER MAY ONLY
BE ENFORCED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THROUGH A CIVIL
ACTION FILED IN SUPERIOR COURT.
SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT GIVES THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER THE AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS.
CONTRACTUAL WAGES THROUGH A
CITATION ISSUED AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER.
THE BILL WILL ENSURE WORKERS ARE
PAID THEIR APPROPRIATE
CONTRACTUAL WAGES THROUGH THE
ISSUANCE OF CITATIONS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO MENTION IT
ALLOWS.
EMPLOYERS TO CONSOLIDATE MATTERS
IN THE CHAMBER HAS REMOVED ITS
OPPOSITION I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MINING.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SING SING NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
HI BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GOT JOINING [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
I'M MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY.
BY COUNTY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
BATES NO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BY. THIRTY TWO YES VOTES SIX NO
VOTES MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
FOUR SB SEVEN OH ONE BY SENATOR
JONES.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN I WON BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATED
FARMS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
CALLING SENATE SB.
SEVEN OH ONE MAKE SURE THE RIGHT
ONE YES I DO CLEANS UP CURRENT
LAW TO PREVENT -- A DUE PROCESS
VIOLATION FOR ONE A WARRANT IS
ISSUED FOR INDIVIDUAL THAT IS
OTHERWISE A LAWFUL GUN OWNER.
PROVISIONS ADDED TO THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE A FEW
YEARS AGO.
MADE IT A CRIME TO HAVE AN
OTHERWISE LAWFUL FIREARM IF A
WARRANT HAD BEEN ISSUED.
FURTHER BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CLARIFIED THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL MUST HAVE KNOWLEDGE
OF THE WARRANT TO BE GUILTY OF
THE GUN OWNERSHIP CRIME.
BUT THE PROVISION WAS MISS
NUMBERED.
AND ATTEMPT TO FIX THE NUMBERING
WAS MADE IN THE MAINTENANCE OF
CODES BILL LAST YEAR.
HOWEVER THIS FIX IS STILL WIDELY
UNKNOWN AND OFTEN OVERLOOKED SB
SEVEN OH ONE CLEARLY STATES
EXISTING LAW THAT A PERSON WITH
AN OUTSTANDING WARRANT MUST HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT WARRANT TO BE
GUILTY OF A MISDEMEANOR. FOR
ILLEGALLY POSSESSING AN
OTHERWISE LAWFUL FIREARMS I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THE POLICE
CHIEFS HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
THING NONE THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
FIVE SB SEVEN FORTY ONE SENATOR
GALGIANI.
ALWAYS CENTER HUESO.
THIS NEW FINDS VERY VERY SMALL --
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN AWAY BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY.
THERE'S AN INTERESTING INVENTION
CALLED GLASSES.
MICHAEL BUT I COULD I COULD LEND
YOU A PAIR.
THANK YOU RESERVE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN AWAY.
THIS IS A BILL THAT --
CONCERNING THE NEED FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY.
AND AND A GREATER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE OPERATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR ALSO.
KNOWN AS KISER THROUGH ITS
ACRONYM.
THE CHI SO AS A NON PROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION
CREATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STATUTE AS PART OF
THE EFFORT TO DEREGULATE.
THE ELECTRICITY MARKET IN THE
LATE NINETEEN NINETIES.
THE GUYS SO MANAGES THE FLOW OF
A LET ELECTRICITY ACROSS BY THE
HIGH VOLTAGE BOLD POWER SYSTEM
THAT MAKES UP 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S AND A SMALL PART OF
NEVADA'S ELECTRIC GRID.
HI SO IS REGISTER BOTH AS A
TRANSMISSION OPERATOR AND A
BALANCE IN AUTHORITY.
WITH OTHER.
OF BE A BALANCING AUTHORITY.
A SIMILAR. TO OTHER BOUNCY TO
THIRTIES THE CRISIS WAS LARGELY
FOR WORK AND REGULATED OR
REGULATED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
HOWEVER UNIQUE TO THE CHI SO AS
COMPARED TO OTHER REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION ORGANIZATION.
IS THE APPOINTMENT OF THE CHI SO
GOVERNING BOARD.
WHO ARE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND REQUIRE
CONFIRMATION BY THE SENATE?
IN RECENT YEARS THERE HAS BEEN%
INCREASED TENSION ON THE ROLE OF
THE CHI SO INCLUDING THE DEBATE
ABOUT X. EXPAND IS GREAT
OPERATIONS TO OTHER STATES.
IN THE WESTERN UNITED STATES.
ADDITIONALLY RECENT ACTIVITY
CONCERNING THE CRISIS WAS
FURTHER INCREASE THE DESIRE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND ITS OPERATIONS.
FRAUD THIS BILL [inaudible]
OF WOOD.
WOULD.
ATTEMPT TO APPLY MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS CURRENTLY APPLIED. TO
OTHER STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE OPEN MEETINGS ACT THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT.
AND IT PROVIDES OVERSIGHT OF THE
BUDGET AND AUTHORITY.
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO CONDUCT AN
AUDIT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BELL.
BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD.
I CAL YELLOW.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I'M MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
I MONEY BY MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BY Y. CASKEY.
HI WIENER AYE WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
NO.
THERE ALSO I MORE LOCK.
PRICE THIRTY ONE NO SIX MEASURE
PASSES.
FILED NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT CENTER GALGIANI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SOME OF THE SOME FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AN ACRYLATE
ABOUT OUR RECORDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS TRANS GENDER
CALIFORNIANS TO PETITION COURTS
TO CHANGE THEIR NAME AND GENDER
TO CONFORM TO THEIR GENERATED IF
IDENTITY.
THE LAW THAT ALLOWS THAT
PERSON'S OLD BIRTH CERTIFICATE
TO BE SEALED AND A NEW ONE
ISSUED AS AN ORIGINAL TO BOTH
PROTECT THAT PERSON'S PRIVACY
AND RESPECT THEIR IDENTITY.
HOWEVER THERE'S NO PROVISION IN
THE LAW AS TO THE TREATMENT OF
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATES AND THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN.
SB SEVEN FORTY ONE WOULD SIMPLY
ALIGN THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE'S MARRIAGE
CERTIFICATES AND THE PER
CERTIFICATES OF THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THE PROCESS FOR UPDATING
THEIR OWN FIRST CERTIFICATE.
THE BILL SPONSORED BY A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
I PORCHES.
NO BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOT.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL I WAS SO.
I TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NOVEMBER.
IOWA CASKEY.
I WINNER BY WILK HI.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT MEASURE
PASSES.
NOW WE MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY NINE SENATOR CAFIERO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 7404% OF THE COMING
GENERAL AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING.
CENTER COPIER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT.
SB SEVEN FORTY FORTY FORTY FOUR
WHICH ADDRESSES CALIFORNIA'S
DAHLE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS AND
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS.
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
AND IT IS ESTIMATED A THIRD OF
THOSE ARE LIVING WITH A MALE
MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE KNOW THAT HAVING PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS LIVING
AND SHELTERED RECYCLING IN AND
OUT OF HOSPITALS AND
INCARCERATION IS COSTLY TO THE
PUBLIC.
AND RESULT IN NEEDLESS SUFFERING
FOR THE HOMELESS AND THEIR
FAMILY.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT LAST FALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION TWO THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE STATE TO ISSUE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IN BONDS TO CREATE TWENTY
THOUSAND UNITS A PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUALS.
RESEARCH SHOWS SUCH HOUSING
KEEPS PEOPLE INDOORS REDUCES
ILLNESSES AND SUFFERING AND
LOWERS PUBLIC COSTS IT'S ALSO A
HUMANE AND COMPASSIONATE
RESPONSE TO A STATEWIDE CRISIS.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR HELPS FOR
FILL THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS BY
CLARIFYING IN STREAMLINING THE
LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
ASSOCIATED SERVICES LIKE THOSE
THAT NO PLACE LIKE HOME BONDS
ARE.
FOR OUR FUNDING N ORDER TO
EXPEDITE EXPEDITE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH.
DISORDERS AND ARE HOMELESS TO BE
SHELTERED AND CARED FOR NO PLACE
LIKE HOME GOT MORE VOTES THAN
ANY OTHER MEASURE ON THE
NOVEMBER BALLOT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO COMMEND MY MY COLLEAGUE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I I'M I'M JUST MY ONLY CONCERN
IS THAT.
WE HAVE A HOMELESS PROBLEM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
PROBABLY EXCEEDS OVER A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT SPECIFIC TO ANY ONE OF
OUR DISTRICTS WE ALL HAVE IT.
CERTAINLY IT'S MORE PREVALENT
AND MORE THE URBAN AREAS.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS
CONTRIBUTING OR HOMELESS CRISIS
IS WE HAVE THE HIGHEST COST OF
HOUSING ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND IF WE'RE REALLY GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT LOWERING THE
PRICE OF A HOUSING WE NEED TO
FOLLOW THE EXAMPLE OF WHAT SB
SIR SEVEN FORTY FOUR IS DOING.
WE NEED EITHER STREAMLINED
SYKORA.
OR ELIMINATE SEEK BUFFER SOME OF
THESE HOUSING PROJECTS THAT WILL
ALLOW FOR A LOWERING OF THE
COSTA HOUSING IT.
IN GETTING SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT.
HAVE TO LIVE IN THEIR CARS WHILE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL HARD TO
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO VOTE ON THE
MEASURE LIKE THAT INSTEAD OF
JUST.
VOTING TO PUT HIM IN THEIR CARS
WHETHER GOING TO SCHOOL HOW
ABOUT DOING SOMETHING TO MAKE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE SO WE CAN GET
THEM OUT OF THEIR CARS.
AND INTO HOMES.
I THINK INDIAN ACTION BY THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE FUTURE AND
NOT STREAMLINING SEE C<c.cyan> AND</c>
REALLY ADDRESSING.
THE HOMELESS PROBLEM WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING
TO CREATE MORE MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING FORCE ON
THE TREETS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE ANYMORE.
SO LET'S LEARN BY EXAMPLE LET'S
NOT RECREATE THE WHEEL LET'S
LET'S PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BY SICK WAS STREAMLINING OR
ELIMINATING SICK BUT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- TO
NEST I HEAR IT'S A YES VOTE SB
SOME.
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU CENTER
STERN ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR JACKSON'S THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
ARE IDEA.
I WASN'T INTENDING TO RISE BUT
IT'S BEEN A FOR YEARS.
THE SEQUEL IS THE ENEMY OF
EVERYTHING GOOD IN THE STATE AND
I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT
SHE WAS THE REASON CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE MIAMI BEACH.
AND IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN THERE
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
OF THE SICK WAS NOT THE PROBLEM
HERE.
THE PROBLEM IS LOCAL LAND USE
DECISIONS THE PROBLEM IS NIMBY
ISM THE PROBLEM IS WE ARE THREE
AND A HALF MILLION UNITS SHORT.
AND THERE IS NO WAY WE ARE GOING
TO BUILD OURSELVES OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM.
AND PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
LANDLORDS BECAUSE OF THE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND NATURE OF HOUSING GET
TO CHARGE WHAT THEY WANT.
THE PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO DO
THINGS LIKE RENT CONTROL.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS VERY
EASY TO SORT OF PASTE OVER WITH
ALL THE SLOGANS THAT SEEK WAS
THE ENEMY WE'VE XPEDITED SEQUEL
IN MANY INSTANCES WE'VE
STREAMLINED IT IN MANY INSTANCES.
I'VE DONE LEGISLATION THAT
EXPEDITES THE PROCESS BECAUSE
PART OF THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN.
THAT IT TAKES SO LONG TO HAVE A
SECRET MATTER HEARD THIS IS NOT
THE ANSWER TO OUR PROBLEM THOUGH
AND IF WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
EXPEDITED REVIEWS AND YOU'LL
NOTE THAT THE OPPOSITION HERE.
COMES FROM BOTH THE SIERRA CLUB
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL BECAUSE
WE HAVE PRIORITIES IN THE STATE
WE HAVE ALREADY TOLD.
THE COURTS THIS LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE THINGS LIKE OUR
SENIORS.
HAVE PRIORITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CASES BEING FILED WE ALSO HAVE A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH
HAS PRIORITIES BECAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. TO A
SPEEDY TRIAL WE'VE HAD INSTANCES
WHERE WE GIVE DISABILITY RIGHTS
FOLKS AN ADVANTAGE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SET THAT IS A PRIORITY.
WE'VE GOT TO BE MORE CIRCUMSPECT
ABOUT HOW WE GO ABOUT THIS AND
INSTEAD OF THROWING DOWN THE
GAUNTLET THAT SICK WAS THE
REASON THAT WE ARE IN THE MASS
WE ARE.
I THINK WE IF WE ARE TRULY GOING
TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS HOUSING
PROBLEM WE HAVE IN THE STATE WE%
NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE REAL
CULPRITS ARE.
AND I AGAIN OF IT NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER WE DO
HAVE DESPERATE NEED FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND
ELSEWHERE.
BUT TRYING TO EVISCERATES SYKORA
IS NOT THE SOLUTION WITHOUT AYE
ORIGINAL.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
ROCK.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT I GET MY MIKE
WORKING I RISE.
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE -- I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IN CERTAIN
CASES TO EXPEDITE MATTERS WE DO
AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTIONS WE
DO IN A VARIETY OF OTHER.
SITUATIONS AND THIS IS CERTAINLY --
EQUALLY A JUSTIFIED IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I WILL TELL YOU
THAT I'M.
VERY VERY DISAPPOINTED THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TOOK A POSITION
ON THIS BILL.
IN MY OPINION IT'S NOT THEIR JOB
TO TELL US WHAT NEEDS TO BE
EXPEDITED AND NOT EXPEDITED.
THEIR JOB IS TO TELL US WHAT
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO GET THE
JOB DONE AND I LET THEM KNOW
THAT AND HEARING IF THEY COME
SEE ME AGAIN I'M GONNA LET HIM
KNOW WHAT AGAIN.
SO WITH THAT HAVING BEEN SAID I
WOULD REQUEST WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
BAKER SAID IRAQ.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER Y. CASKEY MISTER
PRESIDENT I WAS IN -- PER.
ARE GOING TO GET OUT BUT I VOTED
AGAINST THIS.
IN THE TWO COMMITTEES IT'S AGAIN
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA SAID IT'S A WHOLE SLEW
OF EXEMPTIONS THAT WERE
ATTACKING ON THAT THE SECRET
PROCESS RATHER THAN GOING IN
WITH SOME COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
WE LEAVE. TOO MUCH -- DISCRETION
UP TO THE LOCAL DECISION MAKERS
AND I AM BLESSED BE STAYING OFF
THE BILL IN VOTING NOW.
THANK YOU SIR BYE CASKEY CENTER
WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS THE
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW I AGREE THAT.
WE SHOULD AT SOME POINT WE TAKE
A BROADER LOOK -- AND HOW WE DO
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IN
CALIFORNIA AND BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE THAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT FOR NOW THE LAW
IS WHAT IT IS -- AND WE HAVE A
DIRE SITUATION IN TERMS OF
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS IN THE
STATE AND WE'RE EITHER COMMITTED --
TO HOUSING THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT OR WE ARE AND WE KNOW FROM
THE WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND ITS SEQUEL IS BEING USED
TO DELAY.
UNTIL SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION CENTERS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS AND DYING ON OUR STREETS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW -- WHERE WE HAVE A
NAVIGATION CENTER THAT IS THERE
ARE THREATENING TO SUE UNDERSEA
CAUGHT AND THERE IS NO
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE -- WITHOUT
PROJECT -- IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE GET THIS HOUSING DELIVERED
YESTERDAY AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CENTER BARGES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WASN'T PLANNING ON SPEAKING --
ON THIS -- I WILL -- CERTAINLY
BE SUPPORTIVE AND I WANT TO
THANK -- THE AUTHOR OF THIS ITEM --
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
I THINK THE COMMENTS THAT WE
HEARD TODAY NORMALLY -- I THINK
YOU'RE RATIONALLY INFLAME THE
PASSIONS.
BUT SEE WAT IS -- A A SERIES OF
PROTECTIONS ARE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITY IN MY EXPERIENCE
ESPECIALLY THE LOCAL LEVEL.
FORMALLY AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER THAN ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAVING LAND USE
AUTHORITY I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND
EXACTLY HOW SEEK WORK IS NO
LONGER USED MOSTLY AS A SHIELD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT INSTEAD AS AN EXTRACTION
TOOL AS A SORT.
AND I THINK IF WE'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT CHANGING OUR HOUSING STOCK
IN THIS STATE.
GETTING OUT OF THE DEFICIT THAT
WERE IN IN TERMS OF HOUSING AND
AFFORDABILITY.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR ON SOME
OF THE MAJOR IMPEDIMENTS IN ONE
OF THOSE IMPEDIMENTS IN MY
OPINION I THINK FACTUALLY.
IS THAT SEEK WERE CREATES.
ARE ARE A SERIES OF ROAD BLOCKS
THAT HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
BE MISUSED BY ADVOCATES FOR
OTHER THAN ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS.
SO I WOULD STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGE OTHERS IN THIS ROOM TO
SUPPORT -- THIS -- PROPOSED
LEGISLATION -- BECAUSE WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO TO KEEP OUR HEAD IN
THE SAND IF WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A HOUSING STOCK.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE HOUSING MORE
AFFORDABLE WE NEED TO INCREASE
THE SUPPLY.
AND WE WILL NEVER BE SERIOUS
ABOUT ENDING THIS THIS CHALLENGE
UNLESS WE ARE WILLING TO TAKE IN --
A A MERITORIOUS LOOK AT HOW SEE
WHAT HAS EVOLVED ON IN ITS
CURRENT STATE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU CENTER SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
I THANK MS PRESS I JUST WANTED
TO RESPOND TO MY GOOD COLLEAGUE.
FROM A RIVERSIDE -- IT.
NO MORE OR WE SUPPOSED TO TELL
OR IS THE COURTS POST TELL US
WHAT TO DO WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
TELL THE COURT HOW TO RUN ITS
BUSINESS AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
WHEN YOU TELL THE COURTS THE
ONLY A TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAYS WITHIN WHICH TO RULE ON
SOMETHING -- I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IS OUR JURISDICTION -- TO
TELL THE COURTS HOW TO DO THEIR
BUSINESS.
IS AND I THINK UNCONSTITUTIONAL
A DIRECTIVE TO THE BUT I WILL
SAY THIS.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS AND ARE JUST
TRYING.
TO CREATE MORE DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE DEVELOPERS LIKE TO BUILD.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
DONE WITH THE SEQUEL REVIEW.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PERCENTAGE OF CASES THAT ARE
RESOLVED?
PRIOR TO GOING TO LITIGATION OUR
E. WHEN YOU FILE A SEQUEL CLAIM
IT'S THERE'S A REQUIREMENT OF
MEDIATION. EIGHTY FIVE OR 90% OF
THOSE CASES.
ARE SETTLED THROUGH THAT
MEDIATION PROCESS AND ONLY 2% OF
ALL CASES ACTUALLY ARE EVER
FILED THE DEAL WITH SEQUEL.
SO OF THAT 2% 85% ARE RESOLVED
THROUGH THAT MEDI A MEDIATION
PROCESS SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
IF WE REALLY WANT TO FIX THE
PROBLEM NOT JUST OPEN UP THE
STATE. FOR ALL SORTS OF
DEVELOPMENT THAT WE CANNOT DEAL
WITH.
AND I DON'T WANT TO PUT THE
HOMELESS AS OF THE ONE CHILD IN
FRONT LIKE WE DO WITH WOMEN IN
ORPHANS IN WAR.
THE PROBLEM REALLY IS.
A SITUATION WHERE WE'VE GOT A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS THE DEAL WITH
LAND USE AND IF YOU ARE CITY PER
OF SOMEONE WHO CAME FROM CITY
GOVERNMENT YOU HAVE TO BE HONEST
ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BUILD.
WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO BUILD
WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF HIGH END
DEVELOPMENT THAT GOES ON WE
AREN'T BUILDING APARTMENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PROFITABLE
LET'S TAKE A LOOK?
AT WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO
BUILD MORE HIGH DENSITY HOUSING
AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
RESPECTFUL OF THE ENVIRONMENT MY
LAST POINT THAT IF I MAY.
MISTER PRESIDENT MAKE IT IS THAT
PART OF THE DEAL WITH SEQUEL IS
THERE IS ONLY ONE RECOURSE.
AND THAT IS THROUGH THE COURTS.
WE DON'T HAVE A DEPARTMENT THAT
WE CAN GO TO FIRST THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THE PROCESS WE DO.
IF WE REALLY CARE ABOUT REDUCING
THE TIME FRAME AND GETTING
RESOLUTION TO THESE MATTERS.
THEN WE WILL DO MEDIATION
THROUGH THE COURTS WHERE ALMOST
EVERY CASE IS SETTLED SEQUENCE
IS NOT OUR ENEMY THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR JACKSON CENTER
GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO
WASN'T AS SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE
AND TELL I THOUGHT ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED IN MY%
OWN DISTRICT AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE IN SANTA BARBARA THAT
THERE IS MORE THAN SEQUEL ISSUES.
THAT -- AFFECT OUR HOUSING COSTS
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW WITH THE
REGULATION REGULATIONS THAT ARE
PUT ON HOUSING COSTS.
ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
PERMITS FEES AND THINGS THAT
HAVE TO BE APPLIED FOR BEFORE
YOU EVEN PICTURE FIRST A SHOVEL
IN THE GROUND ON HOUSING.
AND THOSE ARE THE LAWS AND
THINGS THAT WE'VE PASSED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT OF IMPOSE THESE
THINGS ON OUR BUILDERS THAT ARE
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I DO HAVE TO COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES BOTH FROM THE
VALLEY AND FROM AND AS THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA.
AND THE IT IS TRUE THAT SECRET
IS A DETERRENT AND AN EXTORTION
OR EXTRACTION MECHANISM THAT IS
NOT DEALT DOES NOT DEAL WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES ALONE.
I CAN TELL YOU A STORY OF A OF
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
THAT WE WERE DOING AND TAFT
CALIFORNIA A RULE AREA.
BUT THERE WAS THIS PARTICULAR
TYPE A SQUIRREL THAT WAS THERE
IT TOOK HIM SEVEN YEARS TO GET
THROUGH THE PROCESS HE HAD TO
TRAP THE SQUIRREL CAPTIONS WORLD.
TRACK IT DO REPORT SENATE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME AND
IT JUST WENT ON AND ON AND ON
SEVEN YEARS LATER THERE WAS
FINALLY RESOLUTION BUT THERE WAS
AN EXTRACTION COSTS THAT HE HAD
TO PAY. TO ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IN ORDER TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE SMALL
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE IN MY RULE
AREA OF MY DISTRICT.
AND SO IT'S JUST -- NOT WRITE
THAT SEQUEL IS BEING USED FOR A
TOOL FOR THAT I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN AT LEAST STREAMLINED A
PROCESS THAT WE DON'T HAVE SEVEN
FORD IN. ELEVEN YEAR DELAYS THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO THE HOUSING
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP
HOUSING -- MOST SO THANK YOU AND
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR GROW SENATOR ALSO.
YES I JUST A ALSO WAS NOT GOING
TO SPEAK BUT I'D LIKE TO SAY.
TO THE SENATOR FROM FRESNO THAT
YOU CAME ABOUT THIS CLOSE TO
CONVINCE ME TO VOTE AGAINST THIS --
I HAD MADE A COMMITMENT BECAUSE
OF THE SPECIFIC USE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE SPECIFIC NEED.
THAT THAT COMMUNITY ARE PART OF
THAT.
THAT PART OF OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS --
AND IF I THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT WAS
GOING TO BE USED AS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE TO JUST GO ON AND ON AND
ON I WOULD NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS.
SO -- I REALLY -- JUST TO LOOK
AT THIS IN THE PIECE THAT IT IS
AND IF THIS IS A VOTE ON SEE
CA THEN I'M AGAINST IT.
IT'S A VOTE AS THE WAY IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED HERE THAT I'M FOR IT
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RAZA SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR STARTING THIS DEBATE --
JUST DAY EVER GONNA THROW
STATISTICS AROUND.
THE REAL TRAGEDY ABOUT SEA QUEST.
SINCE FOR ON THIS SUBJECT IS
THAT 50% OF THE LAWSUITS ARE
ACTUALLY AGAINST GOVERNMENTS.
SO IT'S USUALLY THE TAXPAYERS
THAT.
HAVE TO PAY THE COST -- AND THE
PLAINTIFFS ARE USUALLY
EUPHEMISMS THERE THEY DON'T EVEN
TELL YOU WHO THEY ARE THEY'RE
USUALLY THEY HIDE BEHIND NAMES
LIKE.
CITIZENS FOR A GOOD CAUSE.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO IT IS
IT'S ALL YOU KNOW LOVE LOVE THIS
AND AND AND SWEETNESS AND LIGHT
BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S USUALLY GREEN MAIL IT'S
USUALLY UNIONS TRYING TO UPSET
THE APPLE CART TO EXTRACT MORE
[inaudible] FOR THEIR PROJECTS
IN THEIR JOBS BUT YOU SHOULD AT
LEAST KNOW WHO YOU'RE BEING SUED
BY YOU SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW YOUR ACCUSER.
AND FACE YOUR ACCUSER THERE'S NO
TRANSPARENCY AND SEE SINCE
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU BROCK YOU
BROUGHT UP SEEK WHAT.
SO I I JUST SAID I THINK IT'S
ABSURD THAT WE AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE TO DISCLOSE EVERY
DONOR THAT CONTRIBUTES TO OUR
CAMPAIGNS ABOVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DO
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT WE HAVE
FULL TRANSPARENCY FULL
DISCLOSURE BUT YOU DON'T KNOW
WHO'S SUING YOU UNTIL THE CASE
IS CONCLUDED.
IN SECRET THAT THAT THAT'S AN
ABUSE THAT HAS TO STOP.
SO MISTER PRESIDENT IS SOMEONE
WHO HELPED PUT PROPOSITION TWO
ON THE BALLOT.
AND HELP GET -- NO PLACE LIKE
HOME MOVING FROM THE GET GO WITH.
FORMER SENATOR KEVIN DELEON -- I
SUPPORT SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR MORE LIKE CENTER
STONE.
THANKS AGAIN MISTER.
PRESIDENT I'D AND IMPLEMENT
SPEAKING TWICE BUT I FIGURED WHY
NOT I THINK IT'S VERY HEALTHY
WHEN WE GET INTO THESE DEBATES
ON THE SENATE FLOOR AND FRANKLY
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD DO IT.
MORE OFTEN BECAUSE I THINK WE
NEED TO BRING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES TO THE FOREFRONT AND AND
HAVE A REALISTIC DISCUSSIONS ON
THEM.
YEAH I I GREATLY RESPECT MY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA AND
I KNOW SHE'S VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT -- ABOUT SEQUEL -- AND YOU
KNOW IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
YOU'LL VILIFY DEVELOPERS THAT
OUR OUR CAPITALISTIC PROVIDING
HOUSING AND MY GOODNESS ARE
CERTAINLY ENTITLED TO MAKE A
PROFIT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST STILL TODAY
[inaudible]
OUR IS MUCH IS SEASON THROUGH
THE ASK ABOUT SEE WHAT.
I'M NOT REAL EXCITED ABOUT SEE
WHAT NOT BECAUSE I'M NOT WANTING
CLEAN WATER AND CLEAN AIR.
ALL REMIND THIS BODY IT WAS A
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATION THAT
ACTUALLY BROUGHT SEEK WERE TO
FRUITION.
BUT THERE ARE MANY UNFORTUNATE
LOOPHOLES AND SEE QUIRK.
THAT MAKE IT VERY UNFAIR.
I THINK IT'S VERY UNFAIR.
THAT YOU CAN BE A PLAINTIFF IN
STILL PROJECT A HOUSING PROJECT
AS AN EXAMPLE [inaudible]
UNDER A FALSE PRETENSE OF
HURTING THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND IF YOU LOSE THAT LAWSUIT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PAY THE OTHER
SIDE'S LEGAL FEES BUT IF YOU
PREVAIL IN THAT LAWSUIT.
YOU HAVE TO YOU GET YOUR
ATTORNEY FEES PAID THAT TO ME IS
AN INJUSTICE.
OF JUSTICE.
MY COLLEAGUES HAS ONLY 2% OF THE
CASES MAKE IT TO COURT.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL SETTLED THROUGH
MEDIATION REFERENCES NOT
MEDIATION.
I CALLED EXTORTION.
THEY EXTORT DEVELOPERS EXTORT
GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
OPEN CHECK.
ESPECIALLY FROM GOVERNMENT THAT
HAVE DEEP POCKETS AND THIS IS
WHY WE DON'T SEE.
THE GROWTH OF OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MARKETS THE GROWTH OF OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL GROWTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
WILLING.
TO RISK TAKE A RISK IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU HAVE A CLOUD OF SYKORA?
OVER THEM THEY'RE NOT GOING-[inaudible]
TO TAKE ARREST HOW GIVEN EXAMPLE
THE CITY OF MENIFEE BEFORE THE
CITY I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
WE NEED TO APPROVE A LARGE
SHOPPING CENTER THAT WOULD GIVE
THEM THE FINANCIAL BASE. FOR
THEM TO BECOME A CITY.
THE DEVELOPER WENT THROUGH ALL
THE PROCESS SEES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS SEASON ERA
ARE.
THEY GOT LEASES CIVIC APPROVED
TO THE BANK THEY GET FROM THE
PROJECT AND AT THE LAST MINUTE.
A CITIZEN FROM TEMECULA
[inaudible]
A CASHIER.
AT A LOCAL STORE ONE PERSON
BECAME THE CONCERNED CITIZENS
FOR MENIFEE A CITY SHE DIDN'T
EVEN LIVE IN. FOR THE AREA
MENIFEE.
AND THROUGH THAT SICK WILL
LAWSUIT THEY STOPPED THAT
PROJECT COLDER THEIR RISK OF
LOSING THEIR TENANTS THERE A
LIST OF LOSING THE REVENUE FOR
THE THE LEASE OBLIGATIONS IN
THEIR RISK OF THE SHOPPING
CENTER GOING DOWN.
AND THE UNFORTUNATE THING WAS
THEY ARE AT RISK OF NOT BECOMING
A CITY THEY WANTED LOCAL CONTROL
THE FACT OF THE PUTTING TOGETHER
THEIR OWN POLICE DEPARTMENT
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK THEY
WANTED TO BE INDEPENDENT OF THE
COUNTY [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR IS A GOOD
BILL.
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THROUGH A
MECHANISM THE INITIATIVE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A COULD BE SPENT.
AND I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
TRYING TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
TO GET THESE AFFORDABLE UNITS ON
THE BOOKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE MAYBE WE CAN GET SOME OF
THESE.
UNFORTUNATE PEOPLE AYE COLUMN
THE FORGOTTEN PEOPLE ARE
HOMELESS PEOPLE AND LET'S GET
THEM INTO HOMES AND LET'S GET
THEM INTO THE SERVICES THAT IT
DESPERATELY NEEDS IT'S BILLS
LIKE THIS.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE
HOUSING INTO OUR MARKETS IN
CALIFORNIA QUICKER -- RATHER
THAN DELAYING THE PROCESS AS
SEQUEL OFTEN DOES FOR THOSE
REASONS AGAIN I REGION OF A YES
VOTE SB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
CENTER STONE.
CENTER ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WEIGH IN.
YES I JUST WANT TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
THE CENTER FROM US ANDERSON
DORADO -- IT THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON ONE
PARTICULAR PART OF OUR CURRENT
CRISIS REALLY PROMISE FOR
HOUSING AND AND IT'S NARROW.
AND FOR THAT REASON I'M
RESPONSIBLE.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THE RECALL THE ERROR
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION.
AND IN IN I REALLY APPRECIATE --
I EXPECT THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
COUPLE MORE DISCUSSIONS -- ON
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF SECRET BUT
BUT FRANKLY ON THIS IS A A MUCH
NARROWER BILL -- WE GOT OUT A
LITTLE BIT OFF TOP TOPIC TOP
TALKING ABOUT -- IT PERSONAL
OPINIONS ON ON SEQUENCE AND IT'S
IT'S IT'S GOODNESS ARE OR IT'S
NOT.
THIS BILL IS VERY VERY
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED IT'S
PATTERNED AFTER EXISTING STATE
LAW THAT ALLOWS MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING AND WHAT THIS LAW DOES
WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IS IT SAYS WE ARE GOING TO
INCLUDE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AS PART OF THE FRAMEWORK. FOR
ALLOWING SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED
IN MULTI HOUSING DEVELOPMENT M.
WHERE THE IT'S IT'S BEEN ZONE BY
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION.
IT DID FITS IN WITHIN THEIR PLAN
BUT NOW SUPPORT OF HOUSING IS
PART OF THE PROCESS AS WELL AND
WHAT IT DOES IS -- IT DOES NOT
EVISCERATES SEQUOIA. SIX WHAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN CONDUCTED IN
THESE ZONES.
ALL IT DOES IS GIVE IT
PREFERENCE.
IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM SO THAT
WE CAN GET THESE UNITS.
PLANNED AND BUILT.
AN EXPEDITED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO IT DOESN'T GIVE A
PASS TO SYKORA IT JUST REQUIRES
THAT THERE BE AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROCESS.
WHICH BY THE WAY WE DO ALL THE
TIME.
WE DO IT IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT INSTANCES SO -- THIS
THIS PARTICULAR -- FRAMEWORK
WHICH PASSED A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO BY BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BECAUSE OF THE NIMBIS AND THE
IDEA WAS TO BE ABLE TO GET THESE
MULTI.
FAMILY HOUSING UNITS UP
IDENTIFIED BUILT -- AND AND THEY
HAVE AN EXPEDITED PROCESS SO.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AS WE FOCUS ON
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I PORCHES.
I BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
BY DOT.
BY THE ROUTE SO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
BY THE TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
NO JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH.
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER BY STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI [inaudible]
NO WIENER.
BY WILK HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE
[inaudible]
HI MONNING [inaudible]
STERN. FIVE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TO
MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVES TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
ONE CENTER PORTANTINO.
PASS ON FILE [inaudible]
NOW UP.
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY TWO SB SENATOR DODD.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION AN ACCOLADE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES INCLUDING
THEIR THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS GEO'S
COMMITTEE BILL WOULD SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT EMERGENCY ORDER
ISSUED BY THE DEPARTMENT A. B.
C. IS NOT A FINAL DECISION.
AND FIXES AND UNINTENDED ERROR
FROM LAST YEAR'S AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY TWO IT'S RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT COMMITTEES RESPECTFULLY
ASK ROBERT.
THANK YOU CENTER DOT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS THE CAN AND
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
SEEING [inaudible]
NINE ICE. THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY NICE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO ON THE BILL.
MOVING NOW TO FILEITEM ONE
SIXTY THREE SENATOR DODD.
NO I'M SORRY.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY BY SENATOR DODD
AND ACTUALLY INTO INSURANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB TWO FORTY REQUIRES
TRAINING -- FOR LICENSE
INDEPENDENT ADJUSTERS PRIOR TO
REGISTERING AS AN EMERGENCY
ADJUSTER REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE TO PREPARE A NOTICE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CALIFORNIA LAWS REGARDING.
PROPERTY INSURANCE POLICIES AND
REQUIRES ENSURE TO PROVIDE A
CLAIM IN WITH A SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT REGARDING THE CLAIM.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT.
THANK YOU SIR DODD.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THREE NINE THIS IS A CANNED IT
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE SIXTY FOUR SENATOR NIELSEN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR NELSON AND ACT REALLY TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
SENATE.
ANOTHER BILL RELATED TO THE
DISASTERS THAT HAVE COME TO
AFFECT US SO MUCH.
IN THESE [inaudible]
DIFFICULT TIMES.
HOSPITALS STRUGGLE WITH THEIR
RESIDENT POPULATION DURING THESE
TIMES [inaudible]
AND SOMETIMES THEN OF COURSE
THERE IS A SURGE IN PATIENTS.
IN HOSPITALS IN THE REGION.
OR IN THE AREA IF THEY'RE STILL
AT LEAST AN OPERATION.
SOME OF THESE PATIENTS.
DO NOT REQUIRE A COURT REQUIRE
THAT PARTICULAR LEVEL OF CARE.
AND A GOAL WOULD BE TO GET THEM
INTO.
A LOWER LEVEL OF KERR.
SUCH AS RESIDENTIAL.
CARE WHERE THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
THE CARE OF THE HOSPITAL NOT
BEING NEEDED THEN.
THAT BED CAN BE FREED UP
[inaudible]
EXPENSES DIMINISHED.
BUT THERE AND AND HOSPITAL HAVE
GOT TO COOPERATE.
NOW THERE ARE LOOPHOLES IN THE
LAW THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HERE WHERE BY SOME.
HAVE NOT BEEN AS ACCOMMODATING
AT DIRECTING.
PATIENTS. FOR THOSE LOWER LEVELS
OF CARE.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS. FOR
TRANSFERRING.
PATIENTS THE LOWER LEVELS OF
CARE.
AS I SAID SUCH A SKILLED NURSING.
BUT ALSO IT CREATES A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
THAT ENSURES THAT PROVIDERS.
AREN'T BEING PAID A PREMIUM.
COVERING THESE DISPLACED
PATIENTS.
IT IS NOT A MANDATE.
IT IS REVENUE NEUTRAL.
AND IT DOES ALLOW.
THEN LESS EXPENSIVE BUT THE
QUALITY CARE DESIRED. FOR
PATIENTS IN SUCH IMPACTED
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO OPPOSITION --
HERE IN THIS IN THE LEGISLATURE
SO FAR.
IF WE HAVE ANY DIFFICULTIES WITH
ANY PARTIES WE WILL WORK WITH
THEM WE HAVE NOT CAUSE TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE I ASK
IN IDAHO.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NNE THIS A CANDID FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL [inaudible]
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX SENATOR
RUBIO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
INSURANCE.
THANK YOU PRESIDENTE MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB FIVE
SEVENTY SB FIVE SEVENTY IS
pSPONSORED.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
AND PASS SENATE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WITH NO DISSENTING
VOTES I ALSO TAKE AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE TO ALIGN THE LOW COST
AUTO PROGRAM WITH THE CURRENT
INDUSTRY PRACTICE.
BY ELIMINATING A GENDER
DISTINCTION USE FOR SURCHARGES
RATES IN ADDITION THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW COMMUTING STUDENTS TO
APPLY FOR COVERAGE UNDER THIS
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL ALSO SIMPLIFIES THE
NOTICE GIVEN TO CONSUMERS AND
CODIFIED THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE REGULATIONS TO INCLUDE
EMANCIPATED SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS.
AND FINANCIALLY INDEPENDENT
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
IN THIS PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEN ON THIS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
WHAT WE DO OKAY -- MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI.
HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
HI NELSON.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBER.
OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
I MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MORE LOCK. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SEVEN SENATOR HILL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINE AND I'M A
SENATOR HILL AN ALKALINE WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY NINE
WOULD EXTEND THE EXISTING SUNSET
PROVISIONS FOR STATE OVERSIGHT
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S REQUIRED
CAPITAL PROGRAM.
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THIS BILL ALSO
WOULD EXTEND SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA REGIONAL WATER SYSTEM
FINANCING AUTHORITY.
AND AUTHORIZES THE RFA TO ISSUE
REVENUE BONDS AND TAKE OTHER
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE THE
RELIABILITY OF THE REGIONAL
WATER SYSTEM OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE IT IS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU CENTER HILL ANY
FURTHER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING AND THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT
SENATOR BORCHERS.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR A TWO BY SENATOR
GORGEOUS AND ACT RELATED
VEHICLES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS SP FOUR OH TWO IS A FIVE
YEAR EXTENSION IN YOUR COUNTIES
ADVENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM --
WHICH ALLOWS INYO COUNTY TO
DESIGNATE SPECIFIC COUNTY ROADS
AS COMBINED USE ROUTES FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO PROGRAM
DELAYS THERE'S NT ENOUGH TIME
FOR A COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM.
THE GOALS THIS PROGRAMMER TO
INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY IMPROVE
NATURAL RESOURCE PROTECTION.
REDUCE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
TRESPASS AND MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
ON COUNTY RESIDENTS HIGHER THIS
BILL NOR THE EXISTING PILOT
PROGRAM CREATE A SINGLE NEW
TRAIL OR ROAD.
IT DOES HOWEVER CREATE A BETTER
NETWORK OF TRAILS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY A LEGAL AND
REGULATED MEANS TO ACCESS
EXISTING MAINTAIN TRAILS.
ADDITIONALLY BY HAVING A LINK
TRAIL SYSTEM LAW ENFORCEMENT AS
A TOOL TO PROPERLY DIRECT OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USERS TO
APPROVED ROUTES AND REDUCE THE
NEED. TO POLICE ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BOARD.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CAMBIADO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
I THEIR ALSO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
JONES I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK I'M REAL.
BY NELSON [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY HAMBURG.
HI WHY COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER.
BY WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
WHY KELSEY?
HIGHS THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY NINE SENATOR MORLOCK.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 754% OR MORE LIKE AN
ACTOR LINDA COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
ADDRESS IS A UNIQUE OR NORMAL
PROBLEM MOST HOMEWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE A DIFFICULT
TIME RECRUITING ENOUGH
CANDIDATES TO SERVE ON THEIR
BOARDS.
SO IF THERE ARE JUST ENOUGH
CANDIDATES FOR EVERY OPEN SEAT
OR THERE ARE LESS.
THEN YOU HAVE A SINGLE SLATE TO
VOTE ON I WOULD ARGUE THAT THIS
IS REALLY NOT ELECTION IS JUST
AN IMPROVEMENT OF THIS ARE
APPROVAL OF THE SLATE
[inaudible]
SO YOU.
YOU HAVE AN ELECTION YOU HAVE
MORE CANDIDATES THAN.
SEATS THAT ARE OPEN [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO PRINT AND MAIL OUT
BALLOTS AND LET THE MEMBERSHIP
SELECT THEIR PREFERRED
VOLUNTEERS WHEN YOU HAVE A GOOD
ELECTION BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO DO
IT WHEN YOU ONLY HAVE.
A SINGLE SLATE -- RUNNING
UNOPPOSED AND AND PAYING ALL THE
COST I HAVE ONE CITY IN MY
DISTRICT THAT HAS.
THREE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
WITH. TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED RESIDENCES AND THEY HAVE
TO MAIL OUT.
A BALLOT EVERY YEAR FOR THE TO
THE THREE AT A COST OF TWENTY
THOUSAND SO SIXTY THOUSAND A
YEAR FOR A RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
ALL TO APPROVE A SINGLE SLATE.
SO MISTER PRESIDENT SEVEN SB
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW AN
UNCONTESTED SLATE TO WIN BY
ACCLAMATION THE SAVING
CALIFORNIA'S RETIREES IN COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT AND OTHERS.
PRECIOUS RESOURCES.
SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WAS
ATTEMPTED LAST YEAR BY THE
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE --
REGRETFULLY IT RECEIVED THE VITO
BUT THIS IS THE SAME BILL IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR SENATOR MORE LACK.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING NONE.
THIS BILL IS.
ELIGIBLE -- FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ECHOING
TRIBAL GAMING IN A CLEARING
THEIR THROATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATE MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A PRESENT THANKS
FOR YOUR WORK TODAY SIR SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR RATIFIES.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TRAVEL
CONTACTED HOPE ABOUT A TRIBE IN
HUMBLE COUNTY WITH THE CITY
CALIFORNIA.
WHO -- WHO VALLEY TRIBE IN
HUMBLE HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
TRES LAND BASIS IN THE ENTIRE
GOLDEN STATE HAS WON THE HIGHEST
POPULATIONS OF TRIBAL MEMBERS?
THE COMPACT AUTHORIZES THE TRIBE
TO BEAR OPERATE A MAX IN THE
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE SLOT
MACHINES AT NO MORE THAN TWO
GAMING FACILITIES WERE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MY MCGUIRE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORCHES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO.
I CHANGE.
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
I OUR TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
BY GROWTH.
HI FOR TITLE [inaudible]
I PAN.
ON THE URGENCY CLAUSE.
SIZE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
BILL ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY TWO CENTER SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY BY SENATOR SKINNER
RELATIVE TO INTERNATIONAL
MIDWIVES DAY.
THANK YOU -- MADAM -- MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS THIS
RESOLUTION IS -- TO RECOGNIZE
AND HONOR.
ARE HARD WORKING MIDWIFE'S IN
THE INCREDIBLE. FIVE LIFESAVING
WORK THAT THEY DO ASSISTING THE
DELIVERY OF BABIES BUT IN
ADDITION TO HELPING DELIVER
BABIES.
THEY ASSIST MOTHERS WITH --
PRENATAL CARE.
WITH THE HOUSTON.
FAMILY PLANNING AND
PRECONCEPTION CARE.
AND OF COURSE ONCE THE BABY'S
DELIVERED NEWBORN CARE --
MIDWIFE'S DECREASE INFANT
MORTALITY RATES THE DECREASE
RISK OF PRETERM BIRTH.
THE LOWER HEALTHCARE COSTS IN
THE REDUCE THE RATES OF INDUCED
LABORS.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
ANY OTHER FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS RESOLUTION IT QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS -- ROLL CALL
[inaudible]
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE RESOLUTIONS
APPROVED.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY NOW
MISTER JACKSON RELATIVE TO OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH.
SENATE JACKSON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TO PRESENT
SR THIRTY NINE WHICH
COMMEMORATES MAY IS OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH AND AS SOMEONE
WHO'S JUST HAD A BIRTHDAY I'M
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE TO THIS
FACT.
BUT THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER POPULATION
WILL NEARLY DOUBLE.
BY TWENTY THIRTY WHICH WILL BE
AN INCREASE OF ABOUT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA ARE OVER.
THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE YEARS MORE
AND MORE OLDER ADULTS ARE MAKING
A POSITIVE IMPACT IN OUR STATE
AS VOLUNTEERS AS EDUCATORS AS
MENTORS ADVOCATES AND MORE.
OFFERING INSIGHT AND EXPERIENCE
TO BENEFIT THE STATE AS A WHOLE.
I NOTICE MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
SMIRKING OVER THERE -- SOMEDAY
YOU'LL BE AT THIS AGE TO TO CALL
YOURSELF AN OLDER AMERICAN.
BUT IN FACT.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IS
THIS STATE AGES THERE WE TRY TO
RECOGNIZE AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF OUR AGING POPULATION WE ARE
LIVING LONGER.
WE ARE STILL VIABLE COMPETENT BY%
INTERESTED IN BEING RELEVANT AND
YET -- THERE IS SO LITTLE THAT
IS BEING DONE TO RECOGNIZE THIS.
AGING -- TSUNAMI THAT IS MOVING
IN OUR DIRECTION -- BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND I
RECOGNIZE SOME OF YOU WERE NOT
HERE THEN BUT I WELL REMEMBER
THEN PRESIDENT GERALD FORD.
OFFERS PROCLAIMED OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH AND EVERY YEAR
IN MAY OLDER AMERICANS MONTH
RECOGNIZES THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
OUR SENIOR.
OF AMERICANS ACROSS THE NATION
WE ARE GROWING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WERE A NEGATIVE BIRTH
RATE STATE WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
MAKE SURE OUR SENIORS.
ARE ABLE TO AGE IN PLACE THAT WE
PROTECT THEM FROM THE VAGARIES
OF AGING THE DISABILITIES THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED SOMETIMES AS OUR
HEALTH.
DIMINISHES AND WITHOUT I WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SR THIRTY
NINE ACKNOWLEDGING RECOGNIZING
OLDER AMERICANS MONTH.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS RESOLUTION QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NOW WE MOVE TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATOR BRADFORD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
THREE SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THIS DEALS WITH ELECTRIC VEHICLE
BRED INTEGRATION SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING.
AND THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY FOR
WHILE SB SIX US SIX SEVEN SIX
INSURERS ARE WE START TO
ADDRESSED IMPACTS.
OF VEHICLE CHARGING OF ELECTRIC
CARS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
EDIE'S AT PEAK CHARGING WILL
DEMAND THE LECTURES THE
EQUIVALENT TO ENTIRE NUCLEAR
REACTOR.
IT'S TIME THAT WE GET SERIOUS
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE HAVE GREAT
INTEGRATION HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPLY
AYE RESTRICTS SIMPLY UP FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS MEASURE
QUALIFIES. FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NOW WE MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE
SENATOR ALLEN.
PAT PASS ON FILE [inaudible]
CUSTOM PLAN.
OKAY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE BY SENATOR
ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
THE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS CESKY -- THREE IS PART
OF A PACKAGE THAT I'M WORKING ON
WITH THE CENTER FROM AROUND AT
WHICH ESTABLISHES.
THE OFFICE OF HIGHER EDUCATION A
COURT NATION ACCOUNTABILITY
PERFORMANCE IN THIS.
IS ACCORDING BODY THAT WILL
ARTICULATE STATE GOALS IT WILL
HELP TO COURTNEY BETWEEN HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND ASSIST THE
STATE ESTABLISHING CLEAR HIGHER
EDUCATION AGENDA THAT SIR
STUDENTS AND MEETS ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT AND WORK FORCE
DEMANDS.
THE OFFICE WILL PROVIDE
INDEPENDENT POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE GOVERNOR.
IN PROVIDED VISION TO ENSURE
THAT ACADEMIC AND WORK FOR
SUCCESS -- FOR EXIST FOR FUTURE
AND CURRENT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BY PARDON
SUPPORT.
AND I WAS THE FRESNO VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS IS A CAN OF FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY EIGHT TO THE I'M SORRY --
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUT I WAS NOT FOR ME OKAY AGREE.
THE NOT OFFENDED ALL RIGHT --
MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO SENATOR
BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX BY SENATOR BELL
AN ACT RELATING TO RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS.
AS THE PRESIDENT I'M SORRY MR
BALCO YEAH -- MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF THIS BILL WILL
CREATE A CENTRALIZED DATABASE OF
STATE AND LOCALLY OWNED.
SURPLUS IN VACANT LAND AND
PROPERTIES IDENTIFIED FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- THE BILL SO
COMMONSENSE BILL WHICH WILL SPUR
CONSTRUCTION OUR STATE.
I REGION I VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER BELL ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THIS BILL IS A
CANDIDATE. FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
SINGLE OBJECTIONS MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO BUT NEXT FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR SENATOR
BELL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINE BY SENATOR BILL
AN ACT RELATING TO TAXATION.
MISTER PRESIDENT THIS MATTER.
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS SIMPLY -- A
EXTENSION OF THE EXISTING LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT BY
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THE TAX BREAKS
VIEWS IN A STRUCTURED WAY.
THAT IS NOT SUBJECT TO FEDERAL
TAXATION -- WITHOUT THIS
EXTENSION CALIFORNIA REFER GOAL
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
TO BACK TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE COULD BE
OTHERWISE USED TO FINANCE --
ADDITIONAL FOUR TO A HOUSING --
THE CURRENT LAW SENSORS DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST.
OF THIS YEAR AND WE WANT TO
EXTEND THIS SO.
ARJUNA VOTE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CENTER BELL.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE IS A CANDID FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ANY OBJECTIONS.
SEEING NONE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible] THIRTY EIGHT TWO
ZERO MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY SIX SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETEEN BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO WATER
RESOURCES.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS AYE
PRESENTING SB NINETEEN
PERTAINING TO STREAM GAGES SB
NINETEEN REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES. TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO DEPLOY A NETWORK OF
STREAM GAUGES AND DETERMINE
FUNDING NEEDS FOR REACTIVATING
EXISTING GAUGES.
MANAGING OUR WATER SUPPLY IS
GROWING MORE CRITICAL IN
DIFFICULT DUTY GAPS AND STATE
REGIONAL WATER DATA.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S LOST
THE ABILITY TO MEASURE STREAM
FLOW A VERY IMPORTANT TIED.
OF DATA RESTORING A STREAM
GAUGES OF THE CENTRAL COMPONENT
OF STATEWIDE REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY THERE IS A
STRONG COALITION OF SUPPORT AND
NO OPPOSITION SB NINETEEN I ASK
DR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING NINE MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
<c.green>Y LABOR.</c>
AYE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK ARM RELL
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
BY AMBER.
I HAVE A COUNTY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
I MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ITEM UP. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY BY ENATOR
DODD ENACT WILLING TO SURPLUS
STATE PROPERTY IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THERE.
FOR CENTER DOT MISS PRESENT
MEMBERS SB TWENTY WOULD ALLOW
NAPA COUNTY TO NEGOTIATE WITH D.
G. ASKED TO BY.
THE EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY ACRE
SKYLINE WILDERNESS PARK ENSURING
THAT THIS PRIDE PARK LAND WITH
POPULAR HIKING TRAILS.
IF VIEWS OF THE BAY REMAINS A
PUBLIC PARK IN PERPETUITY.
SB TWENTY WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
TO SELL OR EXCHANGE AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE SCHOLARLY PARK TO
NAPA COUNTY OR THE NAPA COUNTY
REGIONAL OUGHT PARK.
IN OPEN SPACE DISTRICT TO
INSURANCE PRESS -- PRESERVATION --
THERE'S BEEN NO OPPOSITION THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR --
THANK YOU CENTER DIED.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL I PORCHES.
HI BRADFORD.
HI COUNTY AT ALL.
I CHANGE [inaudible]
HI DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
HI [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
I HER TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LABOR [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY HAMBURG OUR KELSEY BY WIENER.
AYE WILK BY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
HI.
HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR WIENER
.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT CENTER LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND MAKING A
PREPARATION THERE.
FOR CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT THE DUE
PROCESS CLAUSE OF THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION.
PROVIDES A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY THAT PROTECTS A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT
TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT LANDMARK
CASE WAS ROE V. WADE SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE NOW
ALMOST HALF A CENTURY LATER.
PEOPLE GROUPS AN INSTITUTION.
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THEY CAN
THINK OF TO RESTRICT ACCESS AND
A SHAME ANY WOMAN WHO CHOOSES TO
HAVE AN ABORTION.
THE OUR FORMER GOVERNOR MAY HAVE
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS NOT
UNREASONABLE FOR A COLLEGE
STUDENT TO TRAVEL OFF CAMPUS TO
ACCESS MEDICATION ABORTION.
I RESPECTFULLY AND PROFOUNDLY
DISAGREE.
MEMBERS JUST THREE YEARS AGO A
GROUP OF COMMITTED UC BERKELEY
STUDENTS STARTED A GRASSROOTS
EFFORT TO BRING MEDICATION
ABORTION TO THEIR ON CAMPUS
STUDENT HEALTH CARE.
AFTER SPEAKING TO THEIR
ADMINISTRATION AND RAISING
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS TO THAT END
THEY WERE STILL REJECTED BY
SCHOOL LEADERS AT WHICH POINT I
WAS ASKED TO LEAVE THE EFFORT
HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
SB TWENTY FOUR IS THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT EFFORT.
THE COLLEGE STUDENT RIGHT TO
ACCESS ACT WOULD REQUIRE ALL ON
CAMPUS SOON HEALTH CENTERS AT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION FOR EARLY PREGNANCY
TERMINATION FOR THEIR STUDENTS
BY JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE RESEARCH FROM UC SAN
FRANCISCO ESTIMATES THAT EVERY
MONTH. FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
STUDENTS AT THE THIRTY FOUR UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES SEEK MEDICATION
ABORTIONS ARE OFFSITE HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES.
CLEARLY IF WE TRULY VALUE TO
ACCESS TO ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
STUDENT SUCCESS IT IS.
CRITICAL THAT THESE HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS EVERY MONTH ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE SERVICES.
ON CAMPUS MEDICATION ABORTION IS
A TWO STEP PROCESS WHERE A
PATIENT TAKES TWO SETS OF PILLS
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO DAYS.
DURING THE FIRST TEN WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY ACCORDING TO A UC SAN
FRANCISCO STUDY MEDICATION
ABORTION IS VERY SAFE WITH MAJOR
COMPLICATIONS OCCURRING IN ONLY
ZERO POINT 3% OF CASES.
MAKING IT SAFER THAN TYLENOL.
AND THE EVER AVAILABLE ****.
THOUGH MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
SUCH AS PREGNANCY OPTIONS
COUNSELING AND CONTRACEPTIVES
NONE CURRENTLY OFFER ACCESS TO
MEDICATION ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND IS CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF THE CARE
ALREADY OFFERED A COLLEGE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS.
SUCH AS DIABETES MANAGEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND THE
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS.
ACCESS IS SEVERELY LIMITED FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS SINCE ONLY 15%.
OF THE CLOSEST OFF CAMPUS
ABORTION PROVIDERS ARE OPEN ON
WEEKENDS MEETING THAT STUDENTS
MAY HAVE TO MISS CLASS EXAMS AND
WORK TO ACCESSIBLE OCEAN WHICH
IS SUPREME COURT AS DETERMINED
TO BE A PROTECTED CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE WERE MUST RECEIVE
THIS CARE WITHIN THE FIRST TEN
WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
AND MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN FIND
OUT THAT THEY ARE PREGNANT UNTIL
THEY ARE FIVE OR SIX WEEKS ALONG.
MEMBERS THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS
NOT JUST A SLOGAN BUT RATHER A
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING TRUE
ACCESS TO ABORTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR STATE.
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS AT
OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
AND COLLEAGUES THE ONE THING I
LOVE ABOUT THE THE SENATORS THAT
WERE VERY COLLEGIAN BODY WE CAN
AGREE TO DISAGREE ON ISSUES AND
WALK OFF THE FLOOR AND STILL.
BE FRIENDS WITH ONE ANOTHER.
AND I CERTAINLY RESPECT MY MY
COLLEAGUE -- FROM CHINO HILLS --
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND I'M NOT.
ON THE FLOOR HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE MERITS OF ROE VERSUS
WADE THE THE LEGALITY OF OF
GETTING AN ABORTION I'M HERE.
STRICTLY TALK ABOUT THE THE
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF THIS TYPE
OF AN ABORTION.
HEALTH.
I BELIEVE THAT CHEMICAL
ABORTIONS IN A MANNER THAT'S
BEING ADMINISTERED JEOPARDIZES
THE HEALTH OF MANY OF OUR YOUNG
WOMEN.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN A
PHARMACIST NOW FOR ALMOST FOUR
DECADES THIRTY SEVEN YEARS IT'S
HARD TO BELIEVE MYSELF.
I NOT ONLY PRACTICE PHARMACY OF
ACTUALLY TAUGHT AT THE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL PHARMACOLOGY.
AND IT'S IN THIS SIX IT'S THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT MAKES ME SO
WEARY.
OF PHARMACEUTICAL ABORTION.
SINCE MIFEPRISTONE WAS APPROVED
IN THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND BY THE
FEDERAL DRUG ADMINISTRATION.
THERE HAVE BEEN MORE THAN FOUR
THOUSAND CASES WERE EXTREME
REACTIONS HAVE OCCURRED
[inaudible]
THIS INCLUDES.
MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND WOMEN
THAT HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED.
THEIR BENTLEYS FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT WOMEN WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE BLOOD LOSS SO SEVERE.
THAT THEY NEED BLOOD
TRANSFUSIONS.
THURMOND AT LEAST TWENTY TWO
DESK DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE. TO
THE DRUG.
IN ADDITION ABORTION IS A HIGHLY
PERSONAL DECISION.
THAT MUST BE MADE BY WOMAN.
AND THERE IS AMPLE AVAILABILITY
TO ABORTION OPTIONS THROUGH THE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THE MINUTE YOU STAND
UP FOR AND SUPPORT.
AND QUALIFIED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS OFTEN.
IN VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE
UNIVERSITY.
AND THAT'S NOT BY.
BY CHANCE.
HAVING CAMPUSES PROVIDE THE
ABORTION PILL GIVES THIS FALSE
SENSE OF SECURITY.
THE YOUNG COLLEGE WOMEN SEEKING
ABORTION THIS IS A MATTER OF
TAKING MEDICATION A COUPLE DAYS
IN A ROW.
IN YOUR PROBLEM WILL BE SOLVED.
AND YOU CAN GO ON AND CONTINUE
YOUR STUDIES.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WOMEN
IN OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
AND GIVEN THEM A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY WITH AN EASY FIX TO
THEIR ABORTION NEEDS DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE A WISE COURSE OF
ACTION.
WHEN THE ABORTION PILL DOESN'T
WORK FOR THE FIRST TIME?
THE WOMAN USUALLY DOESN'T
REALIZE IT IT TAKES TIME.
THIS OFTEN RESULTS IN A SURGICAL
ABORTION BEING REQUIRED IN THE
REST OF THE MOTHER A MUCH
GREATER SENSE THE TIME LAPSE
BETWEEN -- TAKING THE PILL AND
THE SURGICAL ABORTION IS ALLOW
THE BABY TO MATURE. TO A GREATER
EXTENT.
THIS MEANS THAT THE ABORTION
WILL TAKE PLACE AT A LATER DATE.
WHICH INCREASES COMPLICATIONS TO
THE MOTHER SAYS THE BABY IS MORE
FULLY GROWN.
THE MEDICAL ABORTION IS SO MUCH
MORE DANGEROUS BECAUSE THERE IS
NO INTERACTION WITH THE DOCTOR.
DURING THE DRAMATIC EXPERIENCE.
THIS BILL NEEDLESSLY WRESTLER
WIVES OF YOUNG WOMEN.
THEY DESERVE TO GO TO A BONAFIDE
CLINIC.
BE SEEN BY A BONAFIDE POSITION
AND GET THE CONCENTRATED
COMPREHENSIVE CARE.
THAT THEY NEED ESPECIALLY THOSE
CASES WEATHER'S ADVERSE
REACTIONS.
THIS BILL REST A STATE FINANCES
DUE TO THE EXTREME LOSSES OVER
LIABILITY ISSUES WHEN SOMETHING
GOES WRONG.
OF GUARANTEE YOU WE WILL SEE
THAT PLAINTIFF IN A COURT OF LAW
SAYING I DESERVE A HIGHER LEVEL
OF CARE.
I WOULD URGE MEMBERS TO STOP
THIS DANGEROUS BILL BEFORE YOU
HEARD ARE VULNERABLE YOUNG WOMAN.
FOR THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NO VOTE.
YES THANK YOU I MISTER PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS -- TODAY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION SB -- TWENTY FOUR
THIS BILL.
IS A IT IS A MANDATE ON STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS.
WITHOUT ALSO ENSURING THAT THEY
CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF WOMEN.
WHO MAY WANT TO KEEP YOUR
CHILDREN?
THERE IS STRONG EVIDENCE TO SIX
SUGGEST THAT A STUDENT WANTING
ABORTION ALREADY HAS AMPLE
ACCESS WITHIN A FEW MILES OF THE
SCHOOL.
BUT ALSO -- FURTHER WE SHOULD
NOT BE PROMOTING THE USE OF
PUBLIC FUNDS TO PROVIDE
ABORTIONS I KNOW THAT THERE IS A
FINE.
THAT WILL BE SERVED BY PRIVATE --
SOURCES BUT ALSO THE STATE WILL
STILL BE ON THE COSTS FOR
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS THE LANGUAGE ALLOWS
LOCAL AND FEDERAL -- AND
TAXPAYER PUBLIC FUNDING.
AND SO SB TWENTY FOUR WILL ONLY
PLACE MORE BURDENS ON STUDENT
HEALTH CLINICS THAT SHOULD NOT
BE PROVIDING SUCH SENSITIVE
SERVICES SO.
I THINK WE'RE ONLY OFFERING ONE
SOLUTION WHICH IS ABORTION AND
WE COULD BE OFFERING EIGHT FOR
WOMEN WHO -- WOULD PREFER TO
KEEP THEIR NEWBORN BABIES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN --
APPRECIATE IN A VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAID A MORALE CENTER
PAN.
I THANK YOU.
THE PRESIDENT -- SENATORS I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND CERTAINLY AS A PHYSICIAN --
OF AND NOW I'M A PEDIATRICIAN
I'VE COULD ALSO CONSULT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT SAID JACKSON
GYNECOLOGY AND THEY HAVE
EXPRESSED TO ME AND THAT TO THEY
ARE -- IN IN THAT THEY FEEL THAT
THIS IS ACTUALLY WOULD BE A VERY
SAFE APPROACH -- I THINK OUR
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS -- WHICH
ARE OFTEN IF IT'S OUR STAFFS --
PHYSICIANS ON STAFF THAT THERE
THAT DAY -- CAN PROVIDE THIS
CARE IN A IN A SAFE MANNER.
AND THE I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE
DO HAVE AN ACCESS PROBLEM SO WE
CAN TALK ABOUT DISTANCES AND SO
FORTH BUT I THINK IF ANY OF US.
REMEMBER BACK TO OUR COLLEGE
DAYS -- THAT -- YOU KNOW GET
GETTING OFF CAMPUS IS NOT ALWAYS
THAT EASY I MEAN YOU CAN YOU CAN
TRY AND PEOPLE CAN DO IT BUT WE
WE REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE FOR SURE THAT WE PROVIDE
FOR IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
LEGAL.
LEGAL HEALTH SERVICE -- THAT IS --
CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH OF A
GROUP OF STUDENTS ON CAMPUS AND
THAT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE AND SO --
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE ALSO
IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE -- BUT I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHEN WE THINK ABOUT --
THE HEALTH OF OUR STUDENTS AND
THAT INCLUDES TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH -- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED AND IT
WILL BE DONE SAFELY AND IT WILL
BE AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THE STUDENTS WHO
NEED TO HAVE IT I SPEAK AND I
ASK THAT WE FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S UP.
THERE LEYVA YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE TO START WITH
SOME OF THE INACCURACIES THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CONNECT TO MACULA
STATED.
BUT I THINK WHAT I'D REALLY LIKE
TO SAY IS THAT.
WHEN I GOT ELECTED WHEN I RAN
FOR OFFICE I RAN FOR OFFICE
BECAUSE I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WORKERS HAD A GOOD JOB THAT
THEY HAD BENEFITS THEY HAD A
PENSION?
AND THEN.
VERY SOON AFTER I WAS ELECTED I
REALIZE THAT WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE
UNDER ATTACK STILL IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WE HEAR ABOUT ALL
THE TIME WITH PAY EQUITY.
WE HEAR ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THAT STILL HAPPENS DAILY.
AND NOW SOMETHING THAT WAS
DECIDED.
A HALF A CENTURY AGO WE SEE
ATTACKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
WOMEN SHOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
I'M NOT ASKING ANYONE TO HAVE AN
ABORTION BUT I'M SAYING EVERY
WOMAN WHO NEEDS OR WANTS ONE
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS.
AND I STRONGLY DISAGREE THAT THE
WOMEN ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS AND YOU IT
THE INTERESTING THING.
IS THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS THE ONLY
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SAID TO ME THAT
THEY FELT THAT WOMEN HAVE ACCESS
OR ALL WHITE MEN.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
EVER TRIED TO ACCESS AN ABORTION
SO THEY PROBABLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
AND FOR MY COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT MEDICATED
ABORTION NOT CLICK CHEMICAL
ABORTION MEDICATED ABORTION
BEING DANGEROUS WHAT ARE YOU
ASKING FOR DO YOU THINK WOMEN
SHOULD HAVE A SURGICAL ABORTION
WHICH PROVIDE THAT ON CAMPUS.
NOTHING IS PERFECT BUT MEDICATED
ABORTION HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
SAFE AND I WILL.
I JUST CONTINUE TO BE SHOCKED
THAT AT FIFTY TWO YEARS OLD I
HAVE TO FIGHT FOR WOMEN COMING
UP BEHIND ME AND WOMEN STANDING
BESIDE ME. TO HAVE ACCESS THE
RIGHT TO HAVE AN ABORTION AND
THIS STARTED FROM OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AT THE UNIVERSITY
BERKELEY STUDENTS OUR FUTURE WHO
WANT THIS IN ISN'T IT OUR JOB TO
TRY AND HELP THEM.
SO MEMBERS WELL WE SEE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ROLL BACKS ON
WOMEN'S RIGHTS BECAUSE REALLY
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO AN ABORTION.
IS JUST A CONTROL ISSUE IS AND
IT IS JUST TELLING WOMEN WHAT
THEY CAN AND CAN'T DO WITH THEIR
BODY.
IT'S NO ONE'S JOB TO DO THAT AND
NO ONE'S DECISION EXCEPT FOR THE
WOMAN SO LET'S STOP CONTROLLING
52% OF OUR SOCIETY AND LET WOMEN
MAKE UP THEIR OWN MIND AND DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THEMSELVES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BELL.
BY FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO.
EFFORT.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON.
ALL RIGHT JONES.
NO LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
TYLER CASKEY AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
NO.
CENTER LEYVA MOVES A CALL.
NOW WE MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE CENTER WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
WINNER AND AQUINNAH CANNABIS AND
CLING THERE'S THE REF'S TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
AND WIENER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ARE
SENATE BILL -- THIRTY FOUR WHICH
IS ALSO KNOWN AS THE DENNIS
PERON AND BROWNIE MARY OCT -- IT
WILL ALLOW DONATION BASED
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS --
WHICH PROVIDE FREE MEDICAL
CANNABIS TO LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE ILL AND WHO NEED -- TO
WILL ALLOW THESE PROGRAMS TO
PARTNER WITH LICENSE RETAIL
FACILITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE DONATIONS TO LOW INCOME
PEOPLE I CAN HAPPEN -- IT WILL
ALSO ALLOW THAT WILL EXEMPTS
THESE DONATIONS ARE FROM THIS
FROM USE AND CULTIVATION TAXES.
LAST YEAR -- THIS SAME BILL SB
EIGHT TO NINE AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAS OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT --
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THE
ENACTMENT OF PROP SIXTY FOUR IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PUT IN PLACE NEW
TAXES FOR ALL CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
AND OVERSIGHT IN THE DRAFTING OF
THIS BALLOT MEASURE ACCIDENTALLY
SUBJECTED DONATION BASE
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS --
TO THESE COMMERCIAL TAXES EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE NO REVENUE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SELLING
ANYTHING -- THESE TAXES -- AND
FEES -- OR DRIVING IS
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS OUT
OF EXISTENCE AND REDUCING ACCESS
TO MEDICAL CANNABIS BY PATIENTS
WHO NEED THEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL.
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
I GLAZER I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LABOR.
I AM A CHOIR I MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK BY MORALE
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
I THE SENATOR MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY ONE SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION.
THANK YOU I MISS PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS SB.
FORTY FOUR RECOGNIZES THAT WELL
WE'VE MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
CALIFORNIA ON CLEANING OR AIR
AND ANY OF US.
WHO LIVED IN THE LA BASIN IN THE
SIXTIES OR SEVENTIES OR IF
YOU'VE SEEN THE PHOTOS?
YOU KNOW THAT YOU COULD HARDLY
SEE THE MOUNTAINS SHE COULDN'T
SEE THE OCEAN.
THEY WERE IN A HAZE OF SMART.
MUCH OF THAT WAS FROM
PARTICULATE MATTER.
SO WHILE WE'VE DONE MUCH BETTER
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY DIESEL POWERED
VEHICLES FOSSIL FUEL DIESEL
POWERED VEHICLES ARE STILL ONE
OF OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT SOURCES
OF THAT PARTICULATE MATTER WHICH
IS SO HEALTH DAMAGING.
IN WHICH IS NOW.
WE HAVE DATA TO SHOW THAT IT IS
IN.
ASSISTING IN OUR INCREASED
ASTHMA RATES IN VARIOUS CARDIO
PULMONARY PROBLEMS ADDITIONALLY.
WHAT SB FORTY FOUR DOES IS
DIRECTOR AIR RESOURCES BOARD? TO
HELP ESTABLISH A PLAN THAT WOULD
ASSIST US IN MOVING OUR MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
OFF OF THAT.
VERY HIGH PARTICULATE MATTER
FUEL -- WE'VE GOT A LAW DEGREE
PROGRAMS FOR PASSENGER VEHICLES
BUT FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ON THE ROAD NEAR PORTS OR IN
THE TRUCK GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDORS.
THEY ARE.
SUFFERING SEVERELY FROM THIS
MARKET THAT COMES FROM SO MANY
OF THOSE TRUCKS.
THAT ARE POWERED BY THE FOSSIL
FUEL DIESEL.
WE COULD ASSIST THOSE TRUCK
OWNERS NOW THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY NEW VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
AND ALTERNATIVE FUELS.
THE STATE CAN ASSESS.
TRUCKS TO USE A CLEANER TO
EITHER CHANGE THEIR TECHNOLOGY
OR CHANGE THEIR FUEL AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THE CAL CHAMBER HAS MOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SUPPORT IN WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SCENE.
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
HI OR TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BIO CASKEY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
BY.
CENTER SKINNER MOVES THE CALL.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETIES TO SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SAID ABOUT FORTY NUMBER SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACRYLATE ENERGY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND A
MEMBER SO.
WE ALL HAVE THESE VARIATION SAY
WE ALL BUT BUT PRETTYMUCH ALL
OF US HAVE THE SMART PHONES AND
NOW.
OUR HOUSES ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THINGS LIKE -- THERMOMETERS THAT
SAID ARE EITHER ARE ABC'S OR
HEATING SYSTEM THAT CAN BE THEN
CONTROLLED THROUGH OUR THROUGH
ABSENT OR SMARTPHONES.
WE ALSO HAVE -- THEORIES TO
POINTS IS THAT WE CAN TURN OFF
AND ON THROUGH THE APPS IN OUR
SMART PHONES.
THAT'S A GREAT THING BECAUSE YOU
CAN HELP US LIKE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR HOME IS COOL DOWN
BEFORE WE GET HOME MORE WARM
BEFORE WE GET HOME WE CAN USE
THAT SMARTPHONE AND DO THAT
HAPPENED CONTROL THOSE DEVICES.
TO DATE.
OUR ENERGY COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO HELP BRING US VERY
ENERGY EFFICIENT APPLIANCES
WHICH IS GREAT AND DUE TO THAT
WE ARE CALIFORNIA'S PLANTS IS
ARE THE MOST ENERGY EFFICIENT IN
THE U. S..
AND IT'S HELPED US KEEP OUR PER
CAPITA ELECTRICITY USE THE SAME
SINCE THE NIGHT LIKE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NOW WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IS ALLOW THE CVC
TO ALSO.
ENCOURAGE APPLIANCES TO BE ABLE
TO CONNECT WITH THESE APPS IN
OTHER WORDS THAT ARE POINTS IS
BE SMART.
SO THAT WE CAN USE THEM TO
ASSIST IN MANAGING THE DEMAND OF
OUR ELECTRICITY.
RIGHT NOW THE ENERGY COMMISSION
CAN ONLY.
INVOLVED THEMSELVES AROUND
APPLIANCES ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY ALONE IN
NOT IN DEMAND MANAGEMENT WHICH
COULD SO HELP US IT HELPS
CONSUMERS POTENTIALLY REDUCE
YOUR UTILITY BILL.
BECAUSE BY HAVING A SMART
APPLIANCE IN YOUR APP YOU COULD
JUST THE HOW MUCH DATA POINTS IS
DRAWING DURING THE TIMES WHEN
OUR UTILITY RATES ARE HIGHEST.
SO IT MAKES GREAT SENSE FOR
CONSUMERS TO HELP THEM KEEP
THEIR BILLS DOWN BUT IT ALSO
MAKES GREAT SENSE AS WE TRY TO
MANAGE OUR GRID ELECTRICITY.
AND AS WE PUT MORE RENEWABLES ON
THE GRID AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROW [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO LABOR [inaudible]
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY.
I WINNER HI WILK.
HI.
THERE SKINNER MOUSA CALL.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SENATOR
WIENER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY BY SENATOR
WINNER AN ACT RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND CLAIM THEIR THREATS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT KALI SENATE BILL --
FORTY IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT TH HOUSING CONSERVATORSHIP
PILOT PROGRAM THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE OVERWHELMINGLY
PASSED LAST YEAR VIA SENATE BILL.
TEN FORTY FIVE CAN BE
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER
TO SAVE LIVES SB FORTY SETS
CLEAR STANDARDS FOR INITIATING A
CONSERVATORSHIP.
RENEWING A CONSERVATORSHIP AND
FOR ENDING THE CONSERVATORSHIP
UNDER THE PROGRAM.
BY THE BILL REDUCES THE DURATION
OF THE CONSERVATORSHIP FROM ONE
YEAR TO SIX MONTHS IT REQUIRES
THE PROACTIVE NOTIFICATION OF
POTENTIAL CONSERVATIVES.
OF THEIR POTENTIAL ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE CONSERVATORSHIP PROGRAM --
AFTER A SEVEN FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
AND TO BE CLEAR TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS CONSERVATORSHIP YOU
HAVE TO BE FIFTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT
TIMES.
IN A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
BY THE BILL REQUIRES
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES TO MAKE
CONCERTED EFFORTS TO EMPLOYEE
VOLUNTARY SERVICES -- BEFORE
SEEKING A CONSERVATORSHIP IT
ALSO CLARIFIES THE LEGAL PROCESS
FOR CONSIDERING THE USE OF
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT.
AND DETERMINING IT'S A PUT LEGAL
CLICK ABILITY ABILITY TO
POTENTIAL CONSERVATIVES.
LASTLY RECENT AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THE CONSERVATIVES.
CONSERVATIVES OFFICE THIS IMAGE
STATUS REPORTS OF EACH
CONSERVANCY TO THE CORE EVERY
SIXTY DAYS.
IN ORDER TO CONSIDER POTENTIALLY
TERMINATING THE CONSERVATORSHIP
EARLIER -- COLLEAGUES I WANNA BE
VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS PILOT
PROGRAM -- CONSERVATORSHIP AS A
LAST RESORT -- THIS PROGRAM IS
FOR PEOPLE FOR WHOM VOLUNTARY
SERVICE OFFERING OR OFFERING
VOLUNTARY SERVICES HAS NOT
WORKED PEOPLE WHO ARE SO
DETERIORATED AND DYING ON OUR
STREETS THAT THEY NEED EXTRA
HELP.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER JACKSON.
THANK YOU VERY BRIEFLY I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOM SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
TRYING TO FIND THAT SWEET SPOT
ON THIS ISSUE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
THESE ARE FOLKS WHO ARE REALLY --
SO DAMAGED AND SO IS ENDANGERED
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONDITION
CERTAINLY IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF
WE WERE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
SERVICES FOR THEM -- BUT THIS IS
A MEASURE THAT TRIES TO IDENTIFY.
THE THERE ARE.
THERE NEED WITHOUT TAKING AWAY
THEIR LIBERTY AND THIS IS A
MAJOR CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE
FACING IN TODAY'S WORLD I
BELIEVE.
THAT THE SENATOR HAS COME AS
CLOSE TO THAT SWEET SPOT AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN AND SHORT OF
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES
CATCHING THESE PEOPLE BEFORE
THEY BECOME SO.
SIGNIFICANT LEE -- DISABLED
WOULD BE THE ULTIMATE GOAL BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE OFF THE
STREETS THEY NEED THE HELP FOR
THEIR OWN SAFETY.
AND MAY NOT KNOW IT WE HAVE
FOUND THAT SPOT AND I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HIS HARD
WORK AND DILIGENCE AND IN
REACHING THAT POINT INTERACTION
I PHONE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
THING NINE CENTER WIENER YOU MAY
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA.
AND WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS BY BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
BY PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL.
I CHANGE.
I DOT.
I THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I LASER.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LABOR [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
TIME RAIL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG.
I WORK OUT SEE.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK I CENTER WIENER MOVES A
CALL.
AT THIS POINT WE ARE RETURNING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS WE
HAVE THIS IS APPROPRIATE TIME TO
ADDRESS A JOURNEY MEMORIES.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR CENTER GROVE
AND SHE'S NOT AT HER DESK.
SENATOR CENTER BASE ARE YOU
READY TO YOU [inaudible]
YOUR PASSING.
I BELIEVE THIS IS THE LAST TIME
FOR TWO WEEKS SO WE CAN DO
INTERNET MEMORIES THAT TRUE.
PLEASE GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
.
CAN'T THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA LEFT
THE CALLS
[inaudible]
FILED.
FILE ITEM THREE FORTY FIVE AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTY FOUR YEAH.
SO CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GROWTH NO.
HIGHS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY CENTER LEYVA
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA LIVE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT MISTER
SECRETARY.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER SECRETARY WHEN WITH THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY NINE AND GORGEOUS --
TITLE [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY.
HIGHS THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
BILL MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE BY
SKINNER MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS SEVEN MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
SENATOR WIENER.
MISTER SECRETARY BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT.
ONE NINETY TWO ON SKINNER MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I MORE LIKE NO.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SENATOR
WIENER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND ON THE URGENCY DORADO
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI.
PRICE THIRTY SIX NOTES HERE ON
THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO ON THE BILL MEASURE PASSED.
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ACTIONS
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET ME THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
WORKING VERY HARD TODAY IN JUST
THREE HOURS -- AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE HARD WORKING
FLOOR TEAM -- WE'VE PASSED FORTY
TWO SENATE ITEMS TODAY WE HAVE
OUR THREE HUNDRED SIXTEEN SENATE
ITEMS REMAINING.
AND I APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
OF EVERYONE TODAY WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO THIS WEEK AND NEXT.
OZ SO I WOULD STRONGLY URGE AND
SUGGESTS THAT ARE.
WE NOT HAVE MEETINGS OFF THE
FLOOR -- WHERE WE HAVE TO PUT
BILLS ON CALL WE WILL GO MUCH
QUICKER IF WE'RE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY GET THROUGH?
OUR LEGISLATION AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT.
I I WOULD -- AGAIN THANK
EVERYONE AND SAY THAT WE WILL
RECONVENE TOMORROW TUESDAY MAY
TWENTY FIRST AT TEN AM.
THANK YOU.
AS MENTIONED THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED AND WE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW AT TEN AM THANK YOU
MEMBERS